Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere
kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 127 von Raumzeit.
Und heute hat mich der Weg abermals nach Darmstadt geführt,
ins Europäische Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum, dem ESOC, wo hier mal auch alles begonnen
hat und wo man auch immer wieder herkommen muss, weil es hier so viele interessante
Themen zu besprechen geht.
Ja, und nachdem wir uns zuletzt mit Wissenschaft und ganz vielen Teleskopen beschäftigt haben,
wollen wir heute mal wieder uns in einer richtigen Raumfahrtmission zu wenden
und vor allem ein weiteres Mal über Asteroidenabwehr sprechen.
Das haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal gemacht.
Und ja, also machen wir das gleich nochmal. Dazu begrüße ich erstmal meinen
Gesprächspartner, nämlich den Richard, Richard Meusel. Hallo.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Ja, Richard, du bist jetzt gerade erst so.
Wieder hierher gewechselt zum ESOK, weil du ja sonst eigentlich in der italienischen
Sonne gebraten hast. Richtig?
Ja, gebraten nicht unbedingt, aber genossen.
Genau, also ESRIN, meine ich, ist ja einer der ESA-Standorte,
der ja eigentlich auch eine ganz interessante Ausrichtung hat,
also wissenschaftlich auf der einen Seite, dann ist glaube ich die Vega-Raketendevelopment
ist da ja auch mit angedockt ein bisschen, oder?
Und die Earth Observations, deswegen ist unser Near-Earth-Object-Coordination-Center
da so ein bisschen die Sonderlinge, weil die anderen gucken hauptsächlich runter
und wir gucken dann hoch in die andere Richtung.
Genau. Aber jetzt muss hier auch mal wieder in Darmstadt was getan werden.
Ja, das Thema ist tatsächlich hier ein absoluter Wiedergänger bei Raumzeit.
Also ich hatte schon in der neunten Ausgabe mal mit Alan Harris vom DLR gesprochen
über Asteroiden und Kometen an sich und später dann auch mit Detlef Koschny in der 34.
Ausgabe über Space Situational Awareness. Das war so ein bisschen auch der Beginn
bei der ESA, glaube ich, für dieses Thema, kann man sagen.
Ja, das war die Gründerzeit, die Anfangsjahre innerhalb der ESA.
Genau, als es sozusagen losging, bei der ESA nicht nur ins All zu blicken,
sondern eben explizit unter diesem Aspekt mit, wir müssen jetzt einfach mal
verstehen, was da so abgeht.
Es ist nicht einfach mal der leere Raum, sondern wir wissen,
mittlerweile ist da ja eine ganze Menge los.
Nicht nur jetzt mit Asteroiden, sondern eben auch mit sonstigen Raumfahrzeugen
und um einfach da einen Überblick zu bekommen, braucht es entsprechende Koordinierung.
Konkret zur Asteroidenabwehr habe ich mich mit weiteren Kollegen von DIA Rüdiger
Jehn unterhalten, aber das ist jetzt auch schon nach 2018, auch schon fast sieben Jahre her.
Ab und zu gab es hier auch noch mal ein paar konkretere Missionen zu Asteroiden,
die immer wieder besprochen wurden. Heute wollen wir mal ein wenig auf eine
neue Mission blicken, die...
Demnächst beginnen wird, Ramses, die also hier bald die Reise antreten wird
und vielleicht auch Hera, die schon unterwegs ist, da kommen wir gleich zu.
Jetzt muss ich aber natürlich erstmal fragen, Richard, was ist denn eigentlich
mit dir so los, wie bist du denn zur Wissenschaft gekommen und wie hat es dich
denn zur ESA verschlagen?
Zur Wissenschaft während der Universitätszeit. Angefangen hatte ich mal als Lernkandidat,
hatte dann aber das Glück und Vergnügen und die Ehre, in einer Forschungsgruppe
als HIV arbeiten zu dürfen, an Raumsondendaten der NASA-Galileo-Sonde beim Jupiter.
Wieder und das Team war wunderbar.
Das war das Team bei Eberhard Grün, damals im Max-Planck-Institut für Kernphysik
und da habe ich so richtig Feuer gefangen für das Thema.
Das hat mich nicht mehr losgelassen, habe dann mein Physik-Diplom zuerst gemacht,
dann auch in dem Bereich promoviert,
weiter spezialisiert und habe dann mit Daten von Venus Express promoviert und
auch schon wirklich da war ich ein bisschen von der Institutsseite im Betrieb,
der Kamera mit drin und von da aus ging es dann weiter zu Rosetta,
auch noch auf der akademischen Seite,
und ja, irgendwann war dann der Sprung rüber zur ESA für BepiColombo und dann
auch nochmal Rosetta und im weiteren Verlauf dann AIM, HERA und ja,
jetzt halt komplett hauptberuflich für Planetary Defense unterwegs.
Eberhard Grün hatte ich ja auch schon mal bei Raumzeit zu Gast,
zu seinem super Thema Weltraumstaub, dafür ist er glaube ich auch sehr bekannt.
Du hast Physik studiert dann.
Oder? Genau, ja.
Okay.
Okay, das heißt Rosetta, da hast du ja sozusagen schon mit Kometen Bekanntschaft
gemacht, Bibi Colombo ist ja die Mission zum Merkur, die jetzt vor zwei Jahren
gestartet ist, nee, schon ein bisschen länger unterwegs,
2018 ist schon unterwegs, okay, ich hatte ganz früh eine Sendung gemacht,
da war das Ding noch nicht mal unterwegs, aber braucht noch ein bisschen,
also Bibi Colombo ist unterwegs.
Ja, hätte ursprünglich jetzt ankommen sollen, aber die Triebwerker waren ein
bisschen langsam, deswegen machen wir noch eine Ehrenrunde und dann hoffentlich Ende nächstes Jahr.
Okay, also die haben nicht so gut funktioniert, wie man das erwartet hat?
Das sind Prototypen, also man hat quasi in Flight dann ein bisschen getestet
und gelernt, wie sie funktionieren, aber Bibi Colombo macht da tapfer weiter,
auch wenn es länger dauert, man kommt an.
Kommt an. Ist ja, kann ich nur empfehlen, sich nochmal die Sendung anzuhören,
die ich damals gemacht habe.
Ich fand das sehr interessant, weil das ist ja eine der schwierigsten Missionen,
die man überhaupt fliegen kann.
Auf jeden Fall.
Weil es halt einfach so ein bisschen so die Murmel in der Salatschüssel sozusagen,
die eine kleine Kerbe sucht, um darauf zu landen.
Genau, da hatte ich mich damals mit Elsa Montagnon unterhalten.
Ist sie noch bei dem Projekt dabei, weißt du das?
Die ELSA ist über dem Projekt, die ist jetzt schon Department Head am ESAC.
Aha, okay. Bin ich überraschend. Ja, okay.
Und jetzt bist du aber im Planetary Defense Office untergebracht und dort Abteilungschef oder so, ne? Genau.
Klingt ja so nach Superheld, oder?
Ja, klingt spektakulär. Ich meine, ich mutmaße mal, wenn der Begriff Planetary
Protection nicht schon seit den 60er, 70er Jahren schon wirklich eindeutig festgelegt gewesen wäre,
dass man versucht, keine Mikroben
von der Erde oder zu Erde zu transportieren, die nicht sein müssen.
Deswegen hat man da ursprünglich auf der NASA-Seite halt eben nach was Prägnantem
gesucht, um ein bisschen zu erklären, was man macht.
Nicht nur, wie hießen wir früher, Space Situational Awareness Near-Earth Object Segment.
Bis man das ausgesprochen hat, ist der Asteroid schon da.
Und deswegen hat die NASA selbst diesen Begriff zuerst eingebracht.
Und eben um zu zeigen, dass wir eng verzahnt sind, dass es weltweit ist,
dass wir kollegial sind, haben wir das auch für uns übernommen.
Und das machen jetzt andere auch. Also in Japan hat gerade die Arbeit einer
Planetary Defense Gruppe begonnen.
In China, soweit ich weiß, wird da auch was aufgebaut. Und selbst bei anderen
größeren Ländern gibt es da Bestrebungen, da auch entsprechend Spezialisten zu trainieren.
Mit anderen Worten, das Ganze ist natürlich dann wieder sehr international vernetzt,
wie es ja generell in der Raumfahrt eigentlich auch üblich ist.
Also China ist da auch mit im Boot?
Ja klar, also es ist auch ganz wichtig, weil wir sitzen auf einer Kugel,
die dreht sich dauernd und der Asteroid kommt halt aus einer Richtung.
Und wenn man wissen will, was der tut, ist es gut, wenn man nicht immer warten
muss, bis der eine, der dafür zuständig ist, bis er halt dran ist,
in die Richtung zu rotieren.
Es ist halt wichtig, über den ganzen
Erdball und auch auf beiden Nord-Süd-Hemisphären eben Augen zu haben.
Und deswegen Planetary Defense, das ist ein weltweites Unterfangen und es lebt
davon, dass wir alle miteinander die Daten teilen, uns teilhaben lassen,
uns auch sagen, was wir tun.
Da gibt es dann später, wenn es um die weltraumbasierten Sachen geht,
sogar Gremien und Arbeitsgruppen, die eigens dafür eingerichtet sind,
dass so Szenen wie in Don't Look Up, wo der da rumläuft mit diesem riesen Papier-
und Ordnerstapel auf den Armen und wird gefragt, ja, was ist das?
Wie immer hier bei der NASA, was machen denn die anderen? Und dann kommt er
zu dem Schluss, dass die einen dies, die anderen das gemacht haben und am Schluss
hätte sich alles zu null ausgeglichen.
Und das würde in der wirklichen Welt nicht passieren, weil wir alle miteinander
reden und vielleicht nicht unbedingt gemeinsame Pläne schmieden,
wegen politischer Verhältnisse, aber uns auf jeden Fall koordinieren und ein
Gesamtpaket oder eine Gesamtlösung finden würden.
Gilt das auch noch für die russische Raumfahrt derzeit?
Leider hören wir nicht so viel von den Spezialisten dort,
aber es gibt natürlich schon noch Kontakte und Roskosmos ist zum Beispiel jetzt
auch ein Mitglied von Samepage,
also von dieser UN-Arbeitsgruppe, die eben im Bedarfsfall dann Studien und Empfehlungen
an die Vereinten Nationen einreichen soll für einen koordinierten weltweiten Plan.
So, da klingt natürlich jetzt schon an, was sich jetzt verändert hat.
Also bei meinen anderen Gesprächen, also mit Dave Koschny, wir haben es schon
gesagt, das war ja so ein bisschen am Anfang, da hat man sich überhaupt erst
mal aufgestellt und gesagt, okay, das ist jetzt ein Thema für die nächsten Jahrzehnte.
Was ist denn jetzt…,
Was hat man denn sozusagen in der letzten Dekade dann auf den Weg gebracht,
um aus diesen Konzepten jetzt auch wirklich eine funktionierende Space-Situational-Awareness
zu machen oder die Planetenverteidigung aufzustellen?
Funktioniert, würde ich sagen, hat das von Anfang an im Wesentlichen.
Was halt aufgebaut wurde, die Kapazitäten wurden verbessert.
Zum einen die Möglichkeit, Objekte aufzuspüren.
Das sieht man, dass diese jährlichen Entdeckungszahlen, dass die immer noch
so einer schönen exponentiellen Kurve im Groben folgen, wenn man das auf großen Zeitskalen ansieht.
Und das liegt daran, dass es halt immer mehr Beobachter gibt,
spezialisierte Teleskope, die eben darauf abgestellt sind, das gut zu machen, diese Arbeit.
Die Methoden werden verfeinert. Es gibt moderne Methoden, mit denen man halt
ganz anders an die Sache rangehen kann als früher.
Und deswegen, die Entdeckung ist besser geworden, die Raten sind höher geworden.
Auf der wissenschaftlichen Seite dementsprechend auch die Modellierung der Population.
Man versteht deutlich besser das Ausmaß der Gefahr.
Auf jeden Fall auch wichtig ist, dass eben die Bahnbestimmung sehr präzisiert
wurde und die Methoden, die dafür benutzt werden. Also dieses Assessment der
Situation von Einschlagswahrscheinlichkeiten und eventuellen Gefährdungen.
Und last but not least sind wir
jetzt auch so weit, dass dem Ganzen genug Aufmerksamkeit und Bedürfnis.
Dann das Äquivalent von Aufmerksamkeit, das was bringt, das Budget,
beigemessen wird, dass wir eben jetzt dabei sind, eben diese Abwehrkonzepte,
mit wir meine ich jetzt uns weltweit, dass wir dabei sind, diese Abwehrkonzepte
zu entwickeln und tatsächlich zu testen.
2022, DART, das war für mich eine Zeitenwende in der Hinsicht.
Vorher war man sich relativ sicher, dass es mit dem kinetischen Impaktor,
also mit diesem Asteroidenschubsen, dass das machbar ist und dass es effektiv ist.
Aber jetzt ist nach Dart, jetzt ist es gezeigt worden. Jetzt wissen wir,
dass wir dieses Land haben.
Erklär nochmal kurz, was Dart gemacht hat.
Dart war eine Sonde der NASA. Die ist im Spätjahr, im Herbst 2021 gestartet
und schon ein Jahr später, 2022,
auf dem Didymos-Begleiter, die Morphos, dem Kleinen der beiden,
eingeschlagen und hat diesen Bahn um den Großen verändert.
Und das war spektakulär. Die NASA hat damals einen Livestream gemacht und man
konnte wirklich mit einem Bild pro Sekunde da mit Dart mitfliegen,
der zu dem Zeitpunkt schon komplett voll autonom geflogen ist,
was auch wichtig war. Und das war der Test, der da gemacht wurde.
Ob dieser Anflug klappt. Der Rest war Physik. Obwohl, als er dann eingeschlagen
ist, waren wir doch alle sehr überrascht, wie sehr das Ding da gestaubt hat.
Also ich kann mich an Kommentare von Kollegen erinnern. So, ja,
ist er denn noch da, der Kleine?
Und da lag aber auch wirklich eine Erkenntnis drin. Also die Tatsache,
dass das Experiment deutlich effizienter geklappt hat als vorher gesagt,
hat auch dazu geführt, dass man sieht, dass der kinetische Impaktor nicht das
einzige Werkzeug sein sollte, weil es nämlich Umstände gibt,
unter denen man vielleicht lieber langsam und kontrolliert schieben will,
weswegen wir heutzutage, und da sind wir wieder bei dieser Frage des Fortschritts,
was ist denn seitdem passiert?
Wir sind jetzt mittlerweile auch dabei, hoffentlich bald in Orbit zu demonstrieren,
wie ein Beam-Deflection funktionieren würde.
Also dass man einen Asteroiden quasi sanft mit so einem Ionen-Strahltriebwerk
anleuchtet und anpustet, aber das über Jahre hinweg macht und dadurch dann den
kritischen Effekt der Trajektorienänderung kriegt.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, dieser Impact bei DART, das hat besser funktioniert,
als man geglaubt hat. Also man hat da eine höhere Ablenkung gehabt.
Genau, also Missionsziel war die Umlaufperiode um mindestens,
was war das, 72, war das Stated Mission Goal, Minimum, für eine messbare Deflection
sozusagen herzustellen.
Wir hatten aufgrund von den vielen Modellierungen es gab natürlich eine ganze
Bandbreite ich war jetzt in dem Team, das gesagt hat so ungefähr 10 Minuten
das wird schon ordentlich da hat der Regolith und dann kriegt man einen relativ
hohen Beta-Faktor 10 Minuten was?
10 Minuten Änderung in der Umlaufzeit um den Hauptkörper das war so eine Head-on-Collision
und deswegen ist die Umlaufzeit geschrumpft.
Und? Du lagst richtig?
Nee, es waren etwas über 30 Minuten, die sich die Umlaufzeit geändert hat.
Von wie viel? Was ist eine normale Umlaufzeit da gewesen?
Das war so um die zwölf Stunden und war dann über 31 Minuten.
Das ist ja dann schon signifikant. Okay. Und gibt es da eine gute Erklärung dafür?
Ich würde ja mal sagen, das ist ja Physik irgendwie so.
Genau, Physik. Aber eben ganz wichtig ist, man weiß ja nicht,
wie der Körper beschaffen ist.
Wie viel von dem schluckt sozusagen, wie viel der abdämpft?
Im Gegenteil. Also es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so, dass man da zwei Billardkugeln
miteinander kollidieren lässt, wo einfach der Impuls übertragen wird,
sondern es wird ja reingeschlagen, es gibt einen Krater und dann passiert ein
Materialauswurf in die entgegensetzte Richtung.
Und das Material nimmt nochmal Impuls mit. Das ist der sogenannte Beta-Faktor
und der ist größer als 1 gewesen.
Der war da bei 3, ein bisschen was bei Dart. Also es war,
Der Impulsübertrag war deutlich stärker als nur der reine Impuls,
den den Dart mitgebracht hat, eben wegen dem ganzen Auswurf,
der dann nochmal so einen Boost gegeben hat.
Verstehe. Okay, also Dart, um das nochmal aufzugreifen, war ja deine Feststellung,
hat einiges geändert sozusagen in der Betrachtung des Themas.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und das bedeutet, dass jetzt sozusagen andere Methoden jetzt auch nochmal assessed werden.
Genau, also wir wissen jetzt, wir haben diese Methode, wir wissen,
wie lange man gebraucht hat, um es zu bauen, könnte es wahrscheinlich nochmal
schneller machen. Man wüsste im Ernstfall, dass man es hochskalieren müsste,
aber die Daten waren noch unglaublich wertvoll, die daher kamen.
Nur so alles wissen wir noch nicht darüber. Wie sieht er jetzt aus?
Hat er sich rekonfiguriert?
Woraus war er denn? Weil der Ursprungsplan war ja, dass da von der ESA eine
Asteroid Impact Monitoring Mission, AIM, hätte da sein sollen,
hätte das ganze System vorher genau charakterisieren sollen und dann hätte man
gesehen, was da einschlägt.
Das ist, wie man das idealerweise machen möchte. Man möchte nicht in einen unbekannten
Körper einschlagen, sondern idealerweise möchte man wissen, worauf man sich
da einlässt, dass man eben die Parameter, die man beeinflussen kann,
in eine optimale Richtung beeinflusst.
Leider hatte das damals aus Budgetgründen nicht geklappt, aber wir machen jetzt,
sagen wir mal, das, was man dann macht, wenn man es eben danach angucken muss.
Wir fliegen hin mit einer großen Raumsonde, die wirklich tolle Ausrüstung hat,
tolle Instrumente, die dann alles ganz genau unter die Lupe nimmt. Das ist HERA.
HERA fliegt schon, hat schon wunderschöne Daten geschickt vom Mars-Verbeifluß.
Und kommt dann auch im Spätjahr, Dezember nächstes Jahr, also so ungefähr in
einem Jahr, kommt Hera dann an und wird erstmal so eine grobe Charakterisierung des Systems machen.
Und dann passiert was, was auch wirklich so ein bisschen First ist.
Dann klappt Hera zwei Klappen auf und dann kommen die Beibote raus,
nämlich die zwei kleinen Cubesats Juventus und Milani.
Und dann wird dem Ding mal so richtig zu Leibe gerückt. Das wird dann multispektral
aus verschiedenen Blickwinkeln abgeguckt.
Dann wird ein Radarexperiment gemacht, wo Hera mit dem großen Radar,
den anleuchtet von einer Seite und auf der anderen Seite der Juventa-Satellit,
eben das gestreute Radarsignal dann aufnimmt und dadurch Erkenntnisse über das
Innenleben des Asteroiden kriegt. Also das wird sehr, sehr spannend.
Das heißt, einerseits erforscht man quasi diesen Doppelasteroiden nochmal an
sich überhaupt, aber man schaut auch nochmal explizit auf die Auswirkungen dieses Impacts.
Genau.
Also quasi so ein doppelter Nutzen, der da entsteht.
Genau, also Hera ist letztes Jahr im Oktober 2024 gestartet und soll ungefähr
in einem Jahr dort ankommen, möchte ich das richtig sehen.
Jetzt hast du gesagt, Entdeckung ist besser geworden, So in der ganzen Entwicklung,
so in der letzten Dekade.
Wodurch ist die Entdeckung besser geworden?
Also womit entdeckt man denn jetzt so viel besser?
Mehr Teleskope, mehr vor allem sogenannte Surveys, also Suchprogramme am Himmel.
Oder moderne Methoden, eben wie einfach schlicht und ergreifend bessere Kamera-Hardware,
das man einfach tiefer belichten kann mit weniger Zeitaufwand.
Das bringt natürlich dann Abdeckung und oder höhere Magnituden,
die sich erreichen lassen.
Dann ganz neuartige Methoden eben wie Stacking, das viel besser funktioniert
jetzt oder jetzt in neuster Zeit Sachen wie Synthetic Tracking,
wo man einfach belichtet und dann gucken kann, mit welchen Geschwindigkeiten
man zurückstacken müsste um welchen Körper zu kriegen Was belichtet man?
Man belichtet ein Sternfeld kann entweder auf ein vermutetes Ziel tracken oder
halt stillhalten im Prinzip.
Und dann kann man annehmen, dass sich in dem Bild was bewegt hat und gucken,
ob man dann mit diesem Zurückrechnen dann quasi virtuell aufstracken oder synthetisch aufstackt.
Das ist sehr rechenintensiv. Das geht halt eben auch durch die Weiterentwicklung
in der Computer-Hardware.
Ja, und eben auch internationale Vernetzung, Verzahnung, dass man Sachen miteinander optimiert.
Das Atlas-Netzwerk zum Beispiel, das kombiniert viele Sachen zusammen,
das Atlas-Netzwerk. Zum einen die Tatsache, dass moderate Größen mittlerweile
viel bezahlbarer geworden sind bei Teleskopen.
Dann, dass man die mit Computer gestützt eben im Paket als Array betreiben kann.
Und dann, dass man sich weltweit mit verschiedenen Stationen die Surveys so
koordinieren kann, dass die ihre Abdeckung dann optimieren.
Und das ist natürlich auch noch lange nicht am Ende. Im Gegenteil, im Gegenteil.
Momentan sehen wir so ein bisschen seit zwei, drei Jahren, dass das Wachstum
im Moment nicht so stark ist, so ein kleiner Hubbel.
Mal gucken, wie wir am Ende des Jahres rauskommen, ob wir wieder mehr haben
als vorher, aber das war in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren ein bisschen stagniert.
Doch nächstes Jahr erwarten wir dann einen richtig großen Sprung.
Dann geht das Vera Rubin Teleskop mit seinem LSST-Survey online.
Und die haben schon im Testbetrieb gezeigt, dass das wie so ein Schleppnetz
ist, was dann in rauen Mengen Asteroiden reinbringt.
Auch NEOs waren dabei. Dafür ist es nicht optimiert, natürlich.
Das wird bei den Mainbelt dann halt ganz neue Ernte halten.
Aber auch NEOs gab es, ich glaube, 700 Observationen innerhalb einer Woche oder sowas.
Also Near-Earth-Observations.
Genau, Near-Earth-Objects, Erdner-Objekte.
Vera Rubin Observatory war ja hier gerade auch Thema.
Raumzeit 124, vor drei Ausgaben habe ich mich mit Markus Hundertmark darüber
unterhalten, was dort alles Tolles geschehen soll.
Und ja, klar, Asteroiden Survey gehört natürlich mit zu den Aufgaben,
die dieses Teleskop dann übernehmen kann.
Also es wird einfach mehr geguckt, es wird vor allem sehr viel für Survey getan in letzter Zeit.
Es gibt ja noch einige andere Missionen, die sich solchen Aufgaben machen.
Das ist halt einfach gerade so auch das Thema.
Wir wollen jetzt irgendwie alles sehen, richtig schön tief rein,
aber eben vor allem auch diese Beobachtung in Echtzeit.
Das Gaia-Teleskop hat ja auch enorme Datenmengen geliefert und wird ja noch
auf Jahre hin irgendwie ausgewertet werden.
Also wir kriegen schon ganz andere Vorstellungen, glaube ich,
davon, was uns eigentlich alles so umfliegt und es irgendwie,
glaube ich, auch deutlich mehr los, als man vielleicht so erwartet hat, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Man wird sich bewusst, dass eigentlich ständig was an uns
vorbei fliegt, um uns herum.
Und mit dieser Aufmerksamkeit kommt dann auch noch andere Herausforderungen.
Weil das wäre Robin, weil es nur das spektakulärste von der ESA fangen wir jetzt
auch bei den Surveys an mit unserem FlyEye-Netzwerk.
Das ist ein Teleskop, das legt sich ernsthaft mit den Gesetzen der Physik an
und versucht vieles gleichzeitig zu machen, was normalerweise als Trade-off
gemacht wird und hat deswegen auch ein ganz außergewöhnliches Design.
Es wird, glaube ich, schon mal angesprochen, das FlyEye.
Ja, aber wenn man halt mehr entdeckt, man entdeckt es erst mal nicht mit super hoher Präzision.
Wir werden auch bald ganz andere Populationen sehen, weil ins Innere des Sonnensystems
rein, da können wir nicht gut gucken.
Wenn wir jetzt hier am Taghimmel hochgucken, der ist schön blau,
aber Asteroiden sieht man da drin nicht.
Das wird alles durch diese Lichtverschmutzung von diesem großen hellen Balder
in der Mitte des Sonnensystems verursacht.
Frechheit.
Und genau, und das lassen wir uns natürlich nicht bieten auf Dauer.
Und da wollen wir jetzt auch wieder die Welt dran vorbei.
Und da muss man aber in den Weltraum raus. Und dazu hat die NASA jetzt eine
Mission auf dem Weg, den NEO Surveyor.
Das ist ein Infrarotteleskop. Und das soll dann ganz tief da reingucken in diesen
Bereich, weil da versteckt sich noch einiges.
Man sieht bei diesen Entdeckungszahlen, dass selbst die größten Größen noch nicht 100 Prozent sind.
Weil wir wissen, es ist ja noch ein Bereich vom Sonnensystem,
der sehr, sehr schlecht durchmustert ist. und der soll dann durchmustert werden.
Wir wollen dazu auch dann noch komplementär,
Gleich Buddha bei die Fische machen sozusagen und schicken dann noch den Neomir
hinterher. Das gibt das erste Frühwarnsystem auf der Tagseite.
Das ist dann gedacht, um auch kleinere Asteroiden, die der Erde näher kommen,
zu sehen, die sich schneller bewegen, also die eine schnellere Winkelrate im
Himmel haben und die halt durch diesen NEO-Surveyor durchschlüpfen würden,
weil der halt lange in eine Richtung startet, um ganz tief zu gucken.
Und Neomir soll dann halt solche Sachen finden, wie zum Beispiel Chelyabinsk. Typ-Impaktoren.
Das hat 2013 für eine riesen Überraschung gesorgt, der Chelyabinsk-Meteor.
Und das würde er genauso noch heutzutage machen. Wir hätten heute die exakt
gleiche Vorwarnzeit, nämlich Null.
Also Chelyabinsk, ich weiß nicht, wie lange ist das jetzt her? Zehn Jahre oder so?
Februar 2013, ja.
13, genau. Also wir gingen über Russland, eben über Chelyabinsk runter.
Da in Russland so Autokameras sehr verbreitet sind, diese Dashcams,
Gibt es da einige bemerkenswerte Videos davon, aber das hat man dann schon gesehen.
Also ein vergleichsweise kleiner Meteor kann schon eine ganze Menge Ärger machen,
gerade in so einem bewohnten Gebiet.
Also da sind nicht viele Scheiben übrig geblieben. Ist glaube ich nicht wirklich
jemand zu Schaden gekommen, aber in einer etwas dichter besiedelten Region hätte
das wahrscheinlich schon ganz anders ausgesehen.
Also es gab schon über 1000 Verletzte, Gott sei Dank ist niemandem schlimm zu
Schaden gekommen, es gab keine Todesfälle,
aber das war auch, Celia Binsk selbst war schon eine Weile weg von dem,
also ein Stück weg von diesem Event und das war nur die Druckwelt.
Ja, ja, also richtig was los im All und wir schauen zu mit allen möglichen Missionen,
die sich ja am Ende einfach kombinieren und das ist ja im Prinzip dann auch die Idee vom SSR,
von der Space Situational Awareness und damit natürlich hier auch dem Planet Defense,
also einfach erstmal ein Lagebild bekommen und vor allem weiter Forschungsmissionen
losschicken, um zu sehen, okay, was kann man denn jetzt eigentlich machen?
Erläutern doch nochmal so ein bisschen, wie so der ...
Stand der Dinge ist jetzt sozusagen,
also was hat man da jetzt für eine Meldekette, Asteroidenabwehr.
Es wird ja immer wieder mal veröffentlicht, so okay, wir haben jetzt hier wieder
ein Survey gemacht, wir haben da irgendwie was gefunden, da kommt irgendwie
was aus der Dunkelheit des Alls und dann werden ja so Schätzungen rausgegeben.
Wo fliegt das Ding wahrscheinlich hin?
Weil wenn man jetzt mal einen Tag drauf schaut, dann kann man jetzt nicht so
genau sehen, wohin sowas geht.
Wie klackert das jetzt derzeit so rein, wenn so eine Entdeckung in irgendeiner Form gemacht wird?
Also die Sachen werden bei uns vollautomatisch ausgewertet und wir haben zwei Systeme.
Ein System, das ganz frische, neu entdeckte Objekte gleich einliest von meiner
Planet Center, also von den Daten, die die veröffentlichen, wo Gott sei Dank
aus der ganzen Welt alles zusammengesammelt wird.
Und deswegen hat man da wirklich Zugriff auf alle Observationen von meiner Planets
eben, von Kleinkörpern.
Und wenn das Schnellwarnsystem mit dem Namen Meerkat, wenn das was entdeckt, das warnt sofort.
Deswegen habe ich vorhin gesagt, da gibt es eine Art von Benachrichtigung auf dem Telefon.
Das ist dann Meerkat. Also wenn das Erdmännchen anruft.
Dann ist das wichtiger als der Podcast sozusagen.
Wenn das Erdmännchen anruft, dann gucke ich in aller Regel nach.
Und das hatten wir auch schon mal.
Also insgesamt ist es zwölfmal gelungen, kleine Objekte, die auf die Erde zugeflogen
sind, vor dem Eintreten in die Atmosphäre zu entdecken.
Letztes Jahr waren es insgesamt vier, dieses Jahr seltsamerweise bisher null.
Ist halt Small-Number-Statistics.
Aber auf jeden Fall haben wir da eine Möglichkeit, auf direkte Sachen schnell zu reagieren.
Aber die Hauptarbeit, das Herz unseres Systems ist Aegis, benannt nach dem Schild
des Zeus, der die Menschen vor bösen äußeren Einflüssen schützen soll.
Das berechnet Bahn auf 100 Jahre voraus mit allen statistischen Unwägbarkeiten.
Also kann auch so die Bereiche, in denen man es finden könnte,
wenn man alle Messungenauigkeiten und physikalischen Effekte mit einberechnet, vorhersagen.
Und eben diese Systeme, die liefern dann Antworten, gibt es kein Risiko,
das ist dann Null, oder gibt es ein Risiko? und für uns ist die Grenze zwischen
kein Risiko und Risiko, ist sobald es nicht mehr null ist.
Selbst wenn es eins zu einer Million ist, das wird von uns erfasst und auch
übrigens ganz öffentlich auf unserem Portal zur Verfügung gestellt.
Ich habe geguckt, Stand heute sind es knapp 1900 Objekte auf dieser Risikoliste,
von denen wir wissen, dass in den nächsten 100 Jahren eine Chance von nicht null besteht.
Die sind da sortiert nach der Einschlagswahrscheinlichkeit, die man hat.
Die ist im Allgemeinen, hat man einen riesengroßen Bereich, wo er sein könnte.
Und dann fliegt unsere Erde so als kleines Körnle durch.
Und der Moment, in dem sie sich dann in dem Dings befindet, das ist ein Risiko.
Und so grob kann man sagen, die Größe von diesem Bereich verglichen mit der
kleinen Erde, ist dann quasi die Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Das geht aber auch manchmal hoch.
Und da hatten wir Anfang dieses Jahres einen ganz spektakulären Fall,
nämlich den Asteroiden 2024 YR4.
Der wurde so um Weihnachten letztes Jahr entdeckt.
Und dann war aber relativ früh dieses Jahr klar, dass die Einschlagswahrscheinlichkeit
über ein Prozent geht. Und das ist sehr selten noch.
Und beim näheren Beobachten ist die dann erstmal nicht runtergegangen.
Das ist üblicherweise der Fall. Man hat was mit einer höheren Einschlagswahrscheinlichkeit.
Guckt nochmal scharf hin und dann geht das schnell wieder weg.
Aber da war die Bild-Zeitung auch schon auf Temperatur.
Ja, ja, da war die ganze Welt auf Temperatur.
Der Weihnachts-Astri, der irgendwie den Untergang vorbeibringt. Das passt ja wunderbar.
Das war ein enormes Lehrstück.
Aber was ist da bei euch passiert? Also ich meine, was für Aktivitäten triggert das dann?
Also wer hat die Beobachtung gemacht? Wodurch kam das? War das jetzt mehrere
Sachen zusammengeworfen?
Genau, das war im Endeffekt dann, die Entdeckung ist dann meistens noch sehr,
sehr schlecht bestimmt, aber wenn man einen interessanten Fall hat,
dann setzt sich dann jeder drauf, der kann und dadurch wird dann schnell zusammengeschrubft.
Es gibt dann auch immer die Suche nach sogenannten Precoveries,
wo der irgendwo durchs Bild gehuscht ist, weil wenn man schon eine Bahn bestimmt
hat, das erscheint in einem einzigen Bild, dann braucht man keinen Tracklet
wie sonst auch, um das zu linken dann und die Bahn genauer zu bestimmen.
Allerdings war er auf so einer Trajektorie, dass es schwere, mühsame Arbeit war.
Langwierige Arbeit, weil man relativ wenig Hebel hatte, weil er schon aus seinem
Weg dann raus war, Richtung fast zum Jupiter.
Der hat eine relativ stark elliptische Bahn.
Und als der dann über ein Prozent war, der ist so langsam drüber gekrochen.
In unseren Übungen nehmen wir mal an, es hat ein Prozent klar und deutlich überschritten.
Und dann haben wir unsere Übung gemacht mit der Meldekette.
Aber der krocht dann so ewig langsam, da über Tage langsam drüber.
Doch fanden wir uns dann eines Tages an dem Punkt, wo wir gesagt haben,
der geht nicht gleich wieder runter.
Was heißt, ihr habt Übungen gemacht?
Es werden alle zwei Jahre große weltweite Übungen im Rahmen der sogenannten
Planetary Defense Conference.
Und das ist so ein bisschen Wargaming. Da gibt es immer eine kleine abgeschottete
Gruppe von Spezialisten, die rechnen einen physikalisch plausiblen Fall aus.
Und machen natürlich dann, obwohl es steht ihnen frei, den einschlagen zu lassen
oder es einen nahen Vorbeiflug sein zu lassen.
Und die Daten werden dann rausgegeben an die internationale Community und die
spielen dann dagegen und gucken dann, was sie mit diesen Daten machen.
Also sie kriegen dann quasi simulierte Messdaten, simulierte Orbitdaten,
die dann im Laufe der Zeit immer mehr verfeinert werden.
Und da muss man eben seine Reaktion darauf trainieren.
YR4 war das Ganze dann im echten Leben. Lustigerweise waren wir da in der Mitte
von einer groß angelegten Übung der Space Mission Planning Advisory Group,
wo wir angenommen haben, wir haben einen Fall, über 50 Meter, über 1 Prozent.
Wir müssen da reagieren und waren dann dabei, diesen Prozess zu finden,
wie man weltweit diese ganzen Missionsstudien koordiniert. Das ist ja ein gewisser Aufwand.
Und dann ist genau das passiert.
Und dann kam der da mitten in die Übung rein, hat uns die ganze Übung durcheinander gebracht.
Aber das war natürlich dann, Ich meine, das ist ja praktisch dann sozusagen.
In gewisser Weise, ja, weil das war das Ganze dann so ein bisschen im Ernstfall.
Tatsächlich, die Space Mission Planning Advisory Group wurde letzten Endes,
war die nur in Bereitschaft, aber nicht aktiv.
Was aber aktiv wurde bei einem Prozent, ist zum einen unsere Protokolle,
die wir mit unseren Mitgliedstaaten haben und mit einigen anderen,
die quasi auf Anfrage auch daran teilhaben.
Wir haben ein eigenes Meldesystem und eine eigene Meldekette,
wo wir dann Bericht erstatten, sobald was ist.
Da haben wir direkte Kontaktpunkte. Hier in Deutschland zum Beispiel ist das
das Weltraumlagezentrum in Uedem und gleich aber auch das Bundesamt für Bevölkerungs-
und Katastrophenschutz.
Mit denen sind wir direkt über operative E-Mail-Adressen vernetzt und die bekommen
dann von uns einen Lagerbericht in dem Fall war das dann ein Hinweis also war
so wie die gelbe Farbe auf der Wetter-App sozusagen nach dem Motto Achtung da
ist was, das verdient Aufmerksamkeit,
Allerdings, wie gesagt, Planetary Defense, nicht European Defense oder American Defense.
Und dafür, dass die Zahlen da nicht voneinander abweichen, gibt es da das International
Asteroid Warning Network, I-1 ausgesprochen.
Und da sitzen wir halt in einer relativ großen Gemeinschaft zusammen,
und koordinieren uns auch wieder, das heißt wir sagen uns, hey wir haben das
gemessen dann sagen die anderen, wir haben das gemessen und wenn die Zahlen
auch nur minimal abweichen wir hatten da bei Y4 hatten wir am Anfang täglich
Telekonferenzen und haben.
Untereinander rausgefunden ah ihr habt das so gemessen wir haben das so gemessen,
dann sieht man was sind die Unterschiede in den Algorithmen die Rundungsansätze und sowas.
Und dann hat man verstanden, ah ja, okay, euer System kommt auf diese Zahl,
unser System auf diese Zahl.
Die sind nicht 100% gleich, aber die sind verständlich dann.
Und dann einigen wir uns auf so einen, sagen wir mal, gemittelten Wert,
der beide Systeme repräsentiert.
Und das kann dann von diesem Netzwerk offiziell veröffentlicht werden.
Die Idee ist, dass man eben zeigt,
nee, das ist weltweiter Konsens und man spricht da mit einer Stimme.
Tatsächlich hat dieses Warnnetzwerk dann auch zum allerersten Mal die Möglichkeit
genutzt, die Vereinten Nationen, die General Assembly, auch zu informieren.
Das war dann so ein Informationstext, der war sehr ähnlich dem,
was unsere Mitgliedstaaten dann bekommen haben, an Lagebericht,
der wurde den Vereinten Nationen vorgelegt, auch wieder mit dem,
Mit der richtigen Klassifizierung, dass es ein Hinweis ist, dass man da jetzt
nachgucken muss, dass es noch keine Warnung ist oder kein Alarmzustand.
Das hat sehr gut funktioniert, das ist auch sehr gut aufgenommen worden.
Das war zeitnah zu einer UN-Sitzung in Wien und das wurde auch positiv kommentiert,
auch wirklich über alle weltpolitischen Lage hinweg.
Und das ist das, was dann auch wirklich dann weitergegangen wäre.
Der hat dann bei 4 Prozent ungefähr seinen Höchststand gehabt,
was ihn zum Rekord-Asteroiden macht.
Selbst Apophis 2004 hat es nur auf 2,7 Prozent geschafft, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Und es war auch der, der am längsten über einem Prozent war, der Y4.
Und der war tatsächlich 60 Meter, wie sich herausgestellt hat mittlerweile.
Same Page hat nur halt ein bisschen ruhiger reagiert und gesagt,
bis dahin haben wir die Apparition, ob wir jetzt in der Mitte der Apparition
oder einen Monat später irgendwas machen.
Apparition ist die Sichtbarkeit.
Also die Apparition nennt man die Zeit, in der ein Asteroidbeobachtung zugänglich
ist, weil die meisten Asteroiden verschwinden dann in den Tiefen des Weltraums
und gehen zu so hohen Magnituden, dass da nichts mehr drankommt.
Da wurde allerdings am Schluss nochmal mit dem James-Webb-Teleskop gemessen,
als selbst die ganz großen Teleskope der Erde, als es zu dunkel wurde.
Und Samepage hat von vornherein gesagt, wir sind bereit, loszulegen,
aber wir gehen nur in Aktion, wenn wir müssen, damit wir dieses,
weil Samepage ist ja das größte Mittel, was wir haben sozusagen.
Die Space Mission Planning Advisory Group. Das ist sozusagen die,
da wird es dann richtig ernst und wenn Samepage eben eine Empfehlung für ein,
Missionsgesamtkonzept, das kann mehrere Missionen von mehreren Raumagenturen enthalten,
wenn Samepage das vorlegt, dann ist schon, da steht schon eine UN-Resolution
im Raum und deswegen will man sowas nur machen, wenn es nötig ist.
Tatsächlich haben dann die letzten Beobachtungen gereicht, um genug Hebel zu
kriegen, um auszuschließen, dass YR4 auf die Erde trifft.
Das war Weihnachten 2032 ungefähr, kurz danach ging es um einen kritischen Punkt.
Allerdings, was wir noch nicht ganz ausschließen konnten, ist ein Mondeinschlag.
Momentan sind wir bei 4-6% Wahrscheinlichkeit für einen Einschlag auf den Mond von dem Körper.
Wann?
Auch im Dezember 2032.
Alright, das wäre auf jeden Fall ein fettes Ereignis.
Das wäre spektakulär. Da gibt es Berichte aus dem Mittelalter von Mönchen,
die bei der Feldarbeit entdeckt haben, wie dem Mond ein weiteres Horn gewachsen ist.
Also ich würde sagen, auf dem Level spektakulär. Würde das werden, wenn es so käme.
Fände ich ja mal ganz gut. Das ist ja nicht so gefährlich und da kann man dann
wahrscheinlich mit bloßem Auge sozusagen begleiten.
Genau, weil es auf der eher zugewandten Seite ist. Der Vorbeiflug ist zwischen
Erde und Mond und in aller Wahrscheinlichkeit wird es ein Vorbeiflug.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist noch nicht ganz ausschließbar, dass er da auf dem Mond
einschlägt, auf der uns zugewandten Seite.
Wie fühlt sich das denn an? Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt irgendwie...
Gut, YR4, das war dann relativ, wie lange hat das jetzt gedauert?
Ein, zwei Wochen und dann war sozusagen Entwarnung.
Oder? Nein, nein, nein, das war über einen Monat.
Harte, harte Arbeit. Da hat man ja dann sozusagen schon die Aufmerksamkeit der
gesamten Raumfahrt und Space Science Gesellschaft auf dem Planeten, oder?
Da war Medienaufmerksamkeit, das kann man so sagen.
Nicht nur Medienaufmerksamkeit, ich meine, man strahlt ja dann,
glaube ich, auch in die eigene Community auf einmal ganz anders ran.
Also dass alle so ein bisschen vom Platz aufstehen und sagen,
was ist denn jetzt? Weil das könnte ja alles ändern.
Ja, klar, auf jeden Fall. Also wir haben das 100 Prozent ernst genommen.
Es gibt nur das eine, darauf zu reagieren, als ob es eine richtige Bedrohung
ist und alles in Bewegung setzen, vor allem niemals irgendwas zurückhalten.
Zeit, die man nicht kommuniziert, ist verlorene Zeit. Nur wenn man es kommuniziert,
wenn man sich etwas bewusst ist und wenn alle an einem Strang ziehen,
dann kann man optimal irgendwas machen. dagegen. Das ist der oberste Grundsatz.
Und was ist dir so durch den Kopf gegangen, als du den Film Don't Look Up angeschaut
hast? Ich meine, das ist ja im Prinzip genau dein Film, oder?
Der Film war große Klasse. Den habe ich zweimal geguckt. Einmal quasi mit einer
beruflichen Brille auf und einmal nur zum Spaß.
Also ich habe es ja vorhin schon erwähnt, dieser Moment, in dem der da mit den
ganzen Ordnern auf dem Arm kommt und so, ja, also die einen machen dies, die anderen das.
Da musste ich beide Male so loslachen.
Einmal nur aus Entertainment und einmal so, oh wow, ja, wenn wir Same-Page nicht hätten.
Wer weiß. Ist auch irgendwie scary. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt wirklich mal so
den Weltuntergang vorlegt und alle nur so, ach ja, nee, komm.
Da können wir noch Geld draus machen. Schlimmer Gedanke, ne? Oh Mann.
Okay, also es hat sich auf jeden Fall einiges getan und Asteroidenabwehr ist
auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise jetzt schon durchorganisiert.
Also würde jetzt morgen wieder was gemeldet werden oder das Telefon jetzt hier
losgehen, während wir hier noch sprechen.
Ihr wisst sofort, was zu tun ist und der Podcast wäre dann zu Ende.
Ja, was kann man denn jetzt noch besser machen?
Also was sind denn jetzt die nächsten Herausforderungen, um dieses System noch weiterzutunen?
Ich denke mal, ihr seid ja mit den Ideen noch lange nicht am Ende.
Ach nee, noch lange nicht. Wir sind so mittendrin in der ganzen Arbeit.
Also wie vorhin schon erwähnt, die Surveys, es wird zwar mehr und besser und
wir erreichen neue Bereiche, aber das müssen wir noch umsetzen.
Das Flyer-Teleskop ist momentan zum Austesten und zum Einregeln in Matera stationiert,
während das Observatorium auf dem Monte Mufara in Sizilien gerade gebaut wird.
Und das ist eins von diesen Teleskopen. Insgesamt planen wir bis zu vier.
Nummer zwei ist quasi auch schon in Arbeit, da wird jetzt auch schon geguckt, wo steht es dann,
welche technischen Verbesserungen macht man, welche Lehren zieht man aus der
ersten Iteration und das ist einiges, das sieht schon deutlich anders aus,
das FlyEye 2 technisch gesehen.
Wurde unheimlich optimiert. Neom hier muss noch vollends bewilligt werden.
Wir sind in der Studienphase, gebaut werden.
Neosurveyor ist zwar schon weiter, aber muss auch noch gut ankommen.
Und dann, wenn diese ganzen neuen tollen Surveys da sind, dann schütten die uns mit Daten zu.
Vera Rubin first and foremost da in der Richtung.
Und dann geht es aber auch darum, das alles nachzuverfolgen,
weil ein Asteroid ist in erster Linie eine Punktquelle, wirklich eine eindimensionale.
Und so ein Pixel von so einem Detektor ist, wenn man es weit genug weg projiziert,
ein riesen Rechteck, aber Himmel und da ist ja dann am Anfang irgendwo drin.
Das heißt, man braucht eine gewisse Zeit, um den zu bestimmen.
Und wenn man wissen will, was in den nächsten 100 Jahren passiert,
muss man diesen Körper, der da mit zig Kilometern pro Sekunde durch den Weltraum
rast, abmissen auf Genauigkeiten von Millimetern pro Sekunde.
Und das braucht dann eben halt auch Ressourcen, um das nachzuverfolgen.
Da sind wir auch dabei, da kann man dann auch nicht mit beliebig vielen Teleskopen
arbeiten, sondern man muss auch da immer weiter Methoden verfeinern,
das weltweite Vernetzen miteinander verfeinern, dass jeder jedem sagen kann,
hey, du bist gerade in der besten Position, hast das beste Wetter,
bitte mach du jetzt schnell diese Beobachtung.
Das sind die wertvollsten Daten in dem Moment.
Da haben wir in den letzten Jahren auch enorme Fortschritte gemacht und eben
durch diese Asteroiden, die wir jetzt kommen sehen vor dem Einschlag,
Die sind wie ins Fitnesscenter gehen.
Da exerzieren wir wirklich diese ganze Kette von Ereignissen im Schnelldurchlauf,
innerhalb weniger Stunden, was normalerweise Monate brauchen kann,
durch und daraus lernt man dann enorm viel.
Auch die Daten selbst sind wissenschaftlich hochinteressant.
Also da wird einiges gemacht.
Dann eben die Meldeketten noch ein bisschen straffen, organisieren,
da sind wir auch dabei wirklich Prozeduren zu entwickeln, auch mit den einzelnen
Ländern zusammen nationale Vorbereitungspläne auszuarbeiten.
Deutschland ist schon recht weit, aber wir sind auch da noch am Ausarbeiten
von genaueren Sachen dran.
Ja, und letzten Endes dann die Reaktionsmöglichkeiten verbessern.
Das ist das, wo auch noch eine Riesenbaustelle ist, weil wir wissen jetzt,
man entdeckt einen Asteroiden.
Man braucht Monate, bis man rausbekommen hat, dass er eine Gefahr ist und dann geht er eventuell weg.
Er ist eventuell jahrelang weg, YR4.
Wir versuchen zwar schon Anfang nächstes Jahr mit dem James-Webb-Teleskop wieder
draufzuhalten, Aber konventionellen Beobachtungen wäre erst 2027,
2028 wieder zugänglich.
Und das ist alles Zeit. Hoffentlich, und das ist ja die Grundidee,
haben wir im Ernstfall Jahrzehnte Vorwarnzeit, sodass wir was machen können.
Aber man braucht auch bei einem größeren Körper, wenn wir mal mehrere hundert
Meter Durchmesser haben, das ist enorm viel Masse, das ist enorm viel kinetische
Energie, die da gebunden ist und dementsprechend ein enorm hoher Aufwand,
um diesen Impuls in eine andere Richtung zu lenken, den die haben.
Der kinetische Impaktor ist gut, aber um einen großen Körper abzulenken, bräuchte man mehrere.
Man bräuchte ein Gesamtkonzept mit kinetischen Impaktoren, man braucht viele
Raketen, die dann auch wegen heliozentrischer Trajektöre nicht schnell wiederverwertbar
sind in den meisten Fällen.
Es sei denn, wir haben irgendwann mal ganz große, die da Nutzlasten hochschießen können.
Also muss eben dann da weiter an dieser internationalen Koordination gearbeitet werden.
Wir sind noch in dieser Übung der Space Mission Planning Advisory Group,
um eben diese Strukturen zu fördern des weltweiten Zusammenarbeitens,
weil niemand kann dann alleine das machen.
Das ist illusionär. Da muss jeder seinen Teil machen.
Und dann eben, wie schon erwähnt vorhin, insbesondere für tatsächlich kleinere
bis mittlere Bedrohungen, andere Ablenkungsmöglichkeiten, wenn sich da Sachen
ergeben, wo man mit einem kinetischen Impaktor eben nicht….
Effizient genug abwehren kann. Ich mag da nicht so sehr in Details gehen.
Es gibt Limitationen. Zum einen kann man nur in eine Richtung ablenken.
Theoretisch hat man beide Richtungen zur Verfügung. Man kann entweder so schnell
machen, dass er vor der Erde vorbeirauscht oder abbremsen, dass er erst nach
der Erde am kritischen Punkt ankommt.
Der kinetische Impactor kann normalerweise nur bremsen.
Aber ein Ionenstrahltriebwerk, das kann von jeder Richtung einwirken.
Das hat einfach einen Freiheitsgrad mehr, mindestens.
Und man verhindert auch, weil es ist ja enorm viel Energie auf einmal.
In einem Bruchteil einer Sekunde wird da alles gegeben, was mitgebracht wird.
Das sind große Mengen Energie.
Und die können eben dazu führen, dass das Ziel sich zum Beispiel teilweise zerstört.
Also jetzt, ich bemühe da manchmal gar an dieses Bild von der Hydra aus der
grüchischen Mythologie.
Es kann passieren, dass man denkt, man hat dem Drachen einen Kopf abgeschlagen
und dann sind es plötzlich zwei getrennte Schwerpunkte, die dann bei den nächsten
Einschlägen getrennt voneinander behandelt werden müssten, aber noch so nah
sind, dass sie beim Erdeintritt wieder als Gesamtmasse fungieren würden.
Beim Atmosphäreneintritt in die Erde ist das genau genommen.
Und deswegen, Abwehrkonzepte müssen weiter verfeinert werden und die Reaktionszeit.
Weil, um zu verhindern, dass man das falsche Mittel benutzt,
sollte man idealerweise wissen, wo der Asteroid ist.
Und jetzt stellen Sie sich vor, wir brauchen zurzeit vier Jahre,
um eine Aufklärungsmission oder
Abwehrmission zu bauen und irgendwo hinzukriegen, in einem guten Fall.
Man bräuchte vier Jahre zur Aufklärung und dann reagiert man und dann braucht
man vier Jahre zur Abwehr, das sind acht Jahre und dann ist es auch wieder so,
dass das nicht wie von Hollywood skuriert so ist der kommt und dann wird der aus dem Weg geschlagen,
sondern das ist immer noch ein Berg, in den so ein Fiat Cinquecento reinrast,
der hat zwar einen Effekt, aber der Effekt ist sehr klein, das sind auch wieder
diese Millimeter bis Zentimeter pro Sekunde in die gewünschte Richtung,
und mit der Zeit kann sich das natürlich schön aufaddieren.
Wenn man zehn Jahre vor einem Einschlag ablenkt, braucht man viel,
viel weniger Veränderung und viel weniger Aufwand, als wenn man drei,
vier Jahre vor einem Einschlag was abbaut.
Jetzt soll man eine Wasserpistole auf den Tanker einsprühen.
Genau, es hat einen Effekt, aber man muss das eine ganze Weile machen.
Die Wasserpistole auf dem Tanker wäre das Ionenstrahltrieb.
Genau, so stelle ich mir das gerade vor von der Auswirkung her.
Und da müssen wir halt jetzt schneller werden. Und Ramses ist zum Beispiel jetzt
ein Schritt auf diesem Weg, Hera nochmal zu bauen und schneller zu bauen,
um schnell wohin zu kommen. Wir haben nur drei Jahre.
Bis wir loswollen. Aber die Konzepte, die wir verfolgen, gehen dahin,
dass man irgendwann sowas wie standardisierte Mikrosatz oder Cubesatz hat,
die man mit Micro-Launchern losschießt und die dann,
wo man kaum Vorlaufzeit braucht, um die in den Weltraum zu bringen.
Um diese Jahre der Entwicklung auf der Erde, dass man das auf ein Minimum zusammenschrumpft.
Weil das ist alles gewonnene Zeit, die man später für Ablenkung hat,
sollte man sie brauchen.
So das Äquivalent von so Interceptor-Drohnen, die halt irgendwie so schon ready
to run quasi greifbar sind und wenn es dann losgeht, können dann auch sofort losgeschickt werden.
Genau, das ist die finanzielle unerreichbare Utopie. Wir wollen im erreichbaren
und vertretbaren Rahmen da so nah dran gehen, wie es geht.
Okay, ihr seht schon, ihr macht euch auf jeden Fall Gedanken.
So, jetzt kommen wir doch mal auch zu dem nächsten Projekt, beziehungsweise
zu dem nächsten Asteroiden, das ist dann Apophis.
Was ist denn mit Apophis?
Der war 2004 ja super spektakulär, weil da hatte er 2,7 Prozent Einschlagswahrscheinlichkeit
bei über 300 Metern Durchmesser.
Was zu fett ist. Genau, ob das früher schon mal angesprochen wurde.
Ein Zentimeter ist eine Sternschnuppe, ein Meter ist ein beeindruckender Feuerball.
Zehn Meter plus sind wir dann im Bereich von Chelyabinsk, also da wird es schon interessant am Boden.
50 Meter, das geht dann richtig schnell hoch, 50 Meter ist schon Beringer Crater oder Tunguska-Event.
Das heißt, über einer Stadt...
Ist die dann nicht mehr da danach?
Also Tunguska, wo so komplette Wälder platt gewalzt waren.
2000 Quadratkilometer Wald geplättet.
Genau.
Und der Beringer Crater ist eine Meile durchmessender Loch in den Boden.
Bei 50 Meter Durchmesser.
Bei auch 50 Metern Durchmesser.
Und wir reden jetzt von 300.
Und bei Apophis von 300. Das sind sogenannte überregionale Schäden,
die da zu erwarten sind in unserem Jargon. Also das wäre ein Land.
Apophis auf Deutschland, dann wäre das ein anderes Land.
Okay, Schweiz wäre dann platt.
Und da kommt noch Berge dazu. Aber der Teil, das Tal, wo er reingeht, das wäre ganz schlimm.
Okay. So, und der ist seit 2004 bekannt.
Genau, der war zuerst der große, gefährliche Asteroid für eine Weile.
Allerdings konnte man relativ schnell den Einschlag ausschließen.
Das waren dann noch weitere Fragen, weil klar war, 2029 wird ein naher Vorbeiflug passieren.
Da gab es immer dann Ideen, dass der halt durch sogenannte Gravitational Keyholes
fliegen könnte, also quasi in so eine Art Resonanz mit der Erde reingetrieben
wird, wo es ihn dann quasi immer mehr auf die Erde zusteuert durch so kleine
Ablenkungen und kleine Einflüsse.
Und der hat tatsächlich auf der Risikoliste noch sein Dasein gefristet auf einer
sehr hohen Platznummer, weil es klar war, dass es extrem unwahrscheinlich ist.
Er war noch da bis 2021 durch eine konzentrierte Kampagne eben von diesem Asteroiden-Warnnetzwerk
als Trainingskampagne,
wurde dem da genau zu Leibe gerückt, weil da gab es schon einen schönen nahen
Vorbeiflug und da wurde das Ganze auf wenige Kilometer, also am 13.
April am Freitag, den 13.
April 2029 um 21.47 Uhr, glaube ich.
Ich kann mich jetzt bei den Minuten geerbt haben.
Kommt ja der Erde sehr nahe.
Genau, weit innerhalb der, oder nicht weit innerhalb, deutlich innerhalb der
geostationären Distanz.
Das ist nur, was war das, 31.000 Kilometer über der Oberfläche.
Das heißt, da gibt es Satelliten, die ziehen außerhalb vom Apophis ihre Bahn,
beziehungsweise er rauscht da unter denen drunter durch. Und, ähm,
Da wurde dann immer klarer, nee, Moment, der fliegt dann durch unser Gravitationsfeld,
der kriegt die Gezeitenkräfte zu spüren.
Das ist quasi so ein bisschen Dart Light von den wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen
her. Man kriegt ein bisschen was über die Struktur mit.
Er fliegt auch durch den Strahlungsgürtel, das heißt, der Staub könnte da interessante
Sachen veranstalten durch statische Aufladung.
Im Sinne von, könnte geil aussehen?
Nein, wissenschaftlich interessant sein, einfach für die Staubzusammensetzung.
Da sind wir wirklich im Bereich interessante Wissenschaft.
Aber keine optischen Effekte zu erwarten?
Nein, optische Effekte nicht. Es bleibt ein Lichtpunkt für uns.
Aber es ist mit einem Fernglass sehr gut zu sehen und unter den richtigen Bedingungen,
vom richtigen Ort, bei klarem Himmel, wenn man weiß, wo man hinschauen muss, auch mit bloßem Auge.
Wie nah ist er dann dran?
Wie gesagt, etwas mehr als 30.000 Kilometer bei der Oberfläche ist die nächste
Annäherung. und das ist sehr nah.
Wie gesagt, für uns harmlos, aber wenn man auf dem Asteroiden steht,
wird es wahrscheinlich eventuell ein bisschen wackelig, da hoffen wir drauf.
Aber man ist sich mittlerweile sehr sicher, dass das diese 30.000 Kilometer ist.
Ja, auf einen Kilometer, genau. Also das ist wirklich sehr präzise,
ausgemessen und vorhergesagt.
Nur für meine Zeitplanung.
Und es ist halt so gut vorhergesagt, dass man eben, man hat alles da.
Also man hat was Interessantes, was vor der Haustür vorbei rollt.
Es ist ein erdnahe Asteroid, also der ist zwar für die nächsten 100 Jahre gesichert, harmlos.
Aber wenn Sie mich jetzt fragen, die nächsten 10.000 Jahre, da würde ich keine
Aussage wagen, ob er einschlägt oder nicht.
Es ist halt eine gute Möglichkeit, den näher kennenzulernen.
Also auch richtig, dem auf Tuchfühlung zu gehen.
Und letzten Endes dann an dem Punkt, an dem wir gesagt haben,
oh, das ist aber jetzt wenig Zeit, haben wir gesagt, ja, aber Moment.
Das wäre mal eine gute Idee, zu gucken, wie kriegen wir das denn hin,
wenn wir müssen, wenn wir eine Zeit haben.
Also das war auch so ein bisschen eine Herausforderung, die sich da gestellt
hat an uns von dem Asteroiden, hey, kriegt das jetzt noch hin?
Und ja, dem haben wir dann begegnet, wie gesagt, mit mehreren Missionsstudien,
um zu gucken, was ist das beste Konzept.
Ja, wie wird denn jetzt Apophis zur Leibe gerückt werden? Was bieten sich denn
da jetzt für Gelegenheiten?
Was wollt ihr denn da im Wesentlichen untersuchen?
Also im Wesentlichen untersucht werden soll erst vor dem Vorbeiflug charakterisiert werden.
Das, was wir vorhin angesprochen hatten, was bei der anderen Mission noch fehlte.
Also erstmal gucken, was ist das genau?
Genau, das Osiris Apex kommt erst danach, kann zwar sehen, wie sieht er danach
aus, aber dann muss man sehr extrapolieren, um rauszukriegen, was davor war.
Wenn man ihn davor charakterisiert, dann hat man ein viel besseres Verständnis,
was denn genau beim Erdvorbeiflug passiert. Gibt es da so eine Art Beben?
Verteilt sich da Material um? Wie sieht es mit der internen Konfiguration aus?
Und da braucht es schon einiges, um das genau zu wissen. Und deswegen von all
den Konzepten leichtgewichtig, nur mal gucken, wie sieht das Spektrum und die
Form aus der Nähe aus, das wäre das Minimalkonzept gewesen.
Dann gab es Zwischenlösungen, aber letzten Endes kam man zu dem Schluss,
hey, wir haben ja eine Mission, die einem Asteroiden wirklich alle Geheimnisse
entlocken soll, nämlich Hera.
Aber Hera selbst hat ein bisschen länger gedauert, aber hey,
wir haben ja was daraus gelernt.
Was ist, wenn wir das nochmal machen, das ganze System nochmal verschlanken,
ein bisschen simplifizieren, ein bisschen optimieren.
Wie weit kann man das Budget und die Zeit, die gebraucht wird,
reduzieren? Das ist schon so ein bisschen Trainingseffekt auch.
Und so kam dann die Idee zur Mission Ramses.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen sortieren. Also Hera war dieser Doppelasteroid, die Morphos.
Jetzt geht es um Apophis. Und was ist jetzt die Mission, die jetzt quasi diese
Voranalyse machen soll, den Schuss?
Genau, Ramses ist eine Art miniaturisierte, ein bisschen verschlankte Hera,
auch wieder mit zwei Cube-Sats, also kleine Aktenköpferchen und das soll ein
ähnliches Spiel machen.
Okay, also Ramses soll diese Aufgabe übernehmen. Genau, Ramses soll die Aufgabe übernehmen.
Okay, und es gibt aber auch die andere Mission, die Osiris-Apex-Mission.
Genau, das ist die NASA-Mission. Das war vorher Osiris Rex und hat den Asteroiden
Bennu vermessen gehabt.
Und die hat jetzt quasi nochmal ein zweites Einsatzziel bekommen,
ist umbenannt worden in Osiris Apex und ist auf Kurs zum Apophis,
kommt aber erst kurz nach dem Erdnarrn-Vorbeiflug an.
Das heißt, lange Zeit war das eben okay, das ist auch jedenfalls da wieder besser
als nicht nachzugucken, aber man hätte schon gerne was, was vorher auch da ist
und den Part übernehmen wir jetzt.
Okay, aber die beiden Missionen machen im Kern sozusagen das Gleiche,
nur zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten.
Eventuell sogar mit dem gleichen Kamerasystem, weil wir arbeiten da auch sehr
nah mit internationalen Partnern zusammen.
Wie gesagt, die Japaner machen den Launcher, die Amerikaner wollen,
wenn es geht, eine Kamera zur Verfügung stellen.
Das wäre dann das gleiche System wie auf Osiris Apex.
Ja, macht es gleiche, aber eben zu verschiedenen Zeitpunkten.
Aber was ist dann sozusagen die Qualität, das zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt zu
machen? Also ich meine, an so einem Asteroiden ändert sich ja eigentlich nicht viel, oder?
Ja, das ist die Frage. Das ist das große Unbekannte. Was passiert,
wenn der da an der Erde vorbeikommt, sieht die Gezeitenkräfte,
die höheren Gravitationsmomente der Erde und es schüttelt den dann halt wirklich
durch. Wie reagiert er da drauf?
Also man könnte Fragen beantworten, wie wird der jetzt irgendwie geknackt?
Bricht der so ein bisschen ab oder ändert er seine Struktur oder seine Bewegung,
seine Rotation, was auch immer?
Genau, wie ist der Rotationsstand vorher und nachher,
gibt es interne Konfigurationen und eben Ramses hat noch dieses extra,
dass wieder dieses Radarexperiment gemacht wird, dass wieder die Lampe auf der
einen Seite und die Kamera auf der anderen Seite sozusagen und dann wird der
da wirklich wie mit einem Röntgenbild durchstrahlt.
Okay, dann gehen wir nochmal jetzt genau auf die Ramses-Mission.
Was ist da jetzt genau geplant? Erklär doch mal das Setup von dieser Mission
und inwiefern ist das Ding schon im Bau?
Also die Mission Ramses ist jetzt auf der Ministerratskonferenz in Bremen, der ESA.
Da musste das Geld zur Verfügung gestellt werden, um Ramses auch wirklich zu bauen.
Das war bisher eine Absichtserklärung, aber das Geld musste noch quasi ins Konto eingezahlt werden.
Und das ist jetzt passiert. Das Geld ist jetzt zur Verfügung gestellt worden.
Da ging es jetzt nicht nur um die Mission, da ging es generell um die Finanzierung.
Ja, es ging auch noch um die ESA insgesamt. Nee, es war natürlich für uns das
wichtigste Event alle drei Jahre. Da kommen die Mitgliedstaaten zusammen,
der ESA und legen eben ihre Finanzierungslevel fest.
Die ESA hat da zwei Modi, wie Geld zur Verfügung gestellt wird.
Zum einen das sogenannte Mandatory Program, da ist zum Beispiel das Wissenschaftsprogramm drin.
Das ist so eine Art Mitgliedsbeitrag, der errechnet werden kann und wo dann
zum Beispiel ein bisschen mehr gegeben werden kann,
wenn man da Kapazitäten hat oder vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen zurückgenommen
wird, wenn es halt wirtschaftlich in dem Land jetzt halt einfach mal leider nicht anders geht.
Aber es gibt auch sogenannte optionale Programme. Und das ist wirklich,
da steht es den Ländern frei, was zu zeichnen oder nicht, welche Höhe, für was.
Da ist viel mehr Auswahlmöglichkeit.
Es wird oft verglichen mit in ein Restaurant gehen und dann einfach eine Speisekarte
bekommen und sich dann was auszuwählen aus der Speisekarte. Die Speisekarte
ist quasi die Ideen, die ihnen vorgelegt werden und dann wird da gesagt,
das und das und das wollen wir.
Diesmal ist ganz gut gelaufen, diesmal war wirklich so ein komplettes Menü mit
Vorspeise und Dessert auf dem Programm.
Sozusagen, ja genau, weil wir sind ein sogenanntes optionales Programm,
das Space Safety Programm, der Nachfolger vom SSA Programm und wir wurden extrem gut gezeichnet.
Also wir sind über dem, was wir angefragt haben, sind wir gelandet und das ist
natürlich ein großer, großer Erfolg.
Da freuen wir uns riesig.
Wir haben natürlich auch mehr Herausforderungen. Also es ist nicht so,
dass wir jetzt hier jeden Morgen mit Geld duschen oder sowas.
Obwohl es ein sehr großer Erfolg ist, haben wir ja auch große Ambitionen,
in denen große Geldmengen gebunden werden. Jetzt zum Beispiel der Ramses-Mission.
Und wir haben aber auch noch einiges andere, was wir arbeiten.
Und da müssen wir schon mit dem Geld doch sehr haushalten. Also bei aller Freude
ist es nicht so, dass wir Onkel Dagobert jetzt an der Strippe haben.
Nee, aber man merkt natürlich schon, dass jetzt ...
Die ESA und Raumfahrt an sich, glaube ich, ein bisschen ernster genommen wird,
als das so in den letzten Jahrzehnten an manchen Stellen so zu spüren war.
Das hat natürlich viele Gründe, so die geopolitische Lage.
Aber ich denke, dass auch generell die Bedeutung von Raumfahrt so in den letzten
zehn Jahren mit so Projekten wie Starlink und so weiter, also auf einmal so
ganz neue Capabilities dazugekommen sind, natürlich auch ganz andere Probleme,
auch gerade jetzt für Situational Awareness, also die ganzen Satelliten da draußen
und die Probleme, die das macht.
Und jetzt in zunehmendem Maß natürlich auch alte Systeme, die ausfallen und
vielleicht eben noch keine Reserven haben, um ordentlich abgestürzt zu werden etc.
Ich denke, es setzt sich langsam ein bisschen die Erkenntnis durch,
dass es vielleicht mal ganz gut wäre, sich darum zu kümmern,
weil wenn man es nicht macht…,
Droht ja im Prinzip die ganze Raumfahrt an sich zu scheitern.
Also wenn man dann irgendwann wirklich nur noch Weltraummüll da draußen hat,
mal jetzt von den Asteroiden mal ganz abgesehen und einfach überhaupt nichts
mehr starten kann oder bewahre, wenn jetzt eine größere Kollision stattfindet,
die da so eine Kettenreaktion im Orbit auslöst.
Das wäre ja auf so vielen Ebenen katastrophal, da möchte man gar nicht drüber nachdenken.
Aber kommen wir zurück zu Ramses. Also ihr habt jetzt diese Mittel.
Was wollt ihr jetzt genau machen? Was ist schon gemacht worden?
Was wird jetzt in dieser Mission alles umgesetzt werden?
Also es ist schon studiert worden eben, wie man es umlegt.
Alle Vorbereitungsmaßnahmen sind schon gemacht. Es wurde schon zusammengesammelt,
was hat man an Spareparts sozusagen, die man da beitragen könnte.
Es wurde mit internationalen Partnern geredet, was können die beitragen,
wie muss man die Interfaces dann gestalten.
Und jetzt wurde halt der Löwenanteil des Geldes dann zur Verfügung gestellt, um das Bauen zu machen.
Das fängt jetzt wirklich an. Wir haben sogar gestern auch dann schon mit unserem
Programmbord, das ist so ein Aufsichtsgremium, das uns dann leitet,
lenkt und uns das Mandat dann erteilt, das Geld auch einzusetzen und wofür.
Die haben uns gestern auch da schon das Mandat dafür gegeben.
Okay und ihr setzt mehr oder weniger auf die Erfahrung der HERA-Mission auf, technisch.
Was wird dann Ramses sein, womit wird es gelauncht, wann soll er starten und was ist drin?
Das ist dann auch wieder so ein, ich würde mal sagen, so ein mittelgroßer bis
eher auf der kleineren Seite Satellit, wenn man so von klassischen Satelliten ausgeht.
Ist wie gesagt sehr, sehr stark an HERA orientiert, wird also auf jeden Fall
ein Doppelkamera-System haben, Spektralkamera im idealen Fall.
Also Doppelkamera im Sinne von Stereo-Kamera?
Entschuldigung, das war jetzt so einfach, nee, ein redundantes Kamerasystem.
Verstehe.
Also auf jeden Fall auch wieder dieses Konzept, was bei HERA ist,
die Navigation und die operative beziehungsweise wissenschaftliche Datenaufnahme
mit demselben Instrument zu machen, um alles schön schlank und funktional optimiert zu halten.
Es ist auch wieder diese beiden Cube-Sats mit an Bord, Also zwei kleine Aktenkoffer,
von denen einer auch wieder einen Radarempfänger hat.
Beim anderen wird das Payload noch nicht 100% ausgeknobelt.
Da ist noch alles ein bisschen, noch nicht alles, aber da wird noch an Details gefeilt tatsächlich.
Auch an Payloads of Opportunity. Das soll jetzt auch möglichst schnell geregelt werden.
Und die Idee ist dann, das alles jetzt in dem sportlichen Zeitrahmen bis 2028
startfähig zu kriegen und dann im April, Mai 2028 wirklich zu starten.
Das soll dann quasi nur einmal rumgehen und soll dann schon im Frühjahr 2029,
ein bis zwei Monate vor dem 13.
April eben, ankommen und dann eben halt den Asteroiden begleiten mit niedrigen
Relativgeschwindigkeiten.
Das sind immer so diese kleinen hyperbelförmigen Vorbeiflüge,
dass man auch wenn was schief geht, niemals mit dem Objekt kollidiert und da
soll er dann genau unter die Lupe genommen werden und charakterisiert werden,
wie er denn genau aussieht,
wie ist die innere Struktur, was ist die spektrale Zusammensetzung aus der Nähe beobachtet.
Und dann kommt eben dieser spannende Moment, wenn der nah an der Erde vorbeifliegt,
da wird dann hoffentlich in den höchstmöglichen,
äh Modus geschaltet Bilder zu produzieren also wir hoffen da auf so eine Art kleinen Film ähm,
Wo dann eben live geguckt wird, was passiert mit dem Ding, wenn er da an der Erde vorbeifliegt.
Also im Prinzip ist das so ein bisschen Rosetta Light. Also so wie man dem Kometen
einst hinterher geflogen ist und dann mehr oder weniger stationär um den Kometen
herum die genauere Analyse vorgenommen hat.
Ähnliches soll jetzt mit diesem Asteroiden bloß eben sehr viel näher an der Erde getan werden.
Womit soll gelauncht werden? Steht das schon fest, mit welcher Rakete das Ding losgehen soll?
Wir haben sehr, sehr gute Signale und sehr gute Zusagen und Absichtserklärungen aus Japan,
dass man da ernsthaft daran arbeitet, das auf eine sogenannte H3-Rakete zu setzen
und zusammen mit einer japanischen Mission, die dann eventuell auch schon einen
nahen Vorbeiflug in schnellen Amaprofis macht, mit Destiny Plus zu launchen.
Formell eingetragen wird es im April nächsten Jahres. Da müssen wir natürlich
einfach die Prozeduren in Japan dann respektieren, so wie sie sind.
Aber wie gesagt, die klare Absicht ist da und wenn da nichts dazwischen kommt,
wird es auch so passieren.
Wo starten die Japaner ihre Missionen?
Den Weltraumbahnhof habe ich gerade leider nicht präsent. Da habe ich den Namen
vergessen. Aber aus Japan.
Aus Japan, okay, gut. Wir haben das auch schon mal gemacht sozusagen.
Tanegashima Space Center.
Tanegashima.
Genau, das ist eine Insel. Und wahrscheinlich im Süden nehme ich mal an,
damit man schön nah am Äquator dran ist. Ist ja immer ganz hilfreich.
Okay. Ja, ich meine, die Japaner haben ja sehr viel Erfahrung mit Asteroidenmissionen,
Hayabusa und so weiter. Also das ist ja so ein Thema von denen.
Jede Space Agency hat ja so ein bisschen so ihre Schwerpunkte und ihre besonderen Fähigkeiten.
Die Japaner in dem Segment sind schon immer ganz gut unterwegs gewesen.
Von daher ist es wenig überraschend, dass sie da mit dabei sind.
So, das heißt, das Ding geht dann hoch und muss sich quasi auf eine Umlaufbahn
um die Erde bringen, die dann mehr oder weniger synchron ist.
Das heißt, wenn dann, also synchron mit dem Asteroiden meine ich,
also wenn der dann sozusagen reinkommt, dann will man mehr oder weniger direkt dahinter einscheren.
Also der fährt so über die Autobahn und man muss im richtigen Moment auf die
Autobahn drauf fahren, um dann quasi direkt dahinter zu sein.
Genau, die Umlaufbahn ist um die Sonne. Tatsächlich haben wir nämlich so angefangen
mit einer erdgebundenen Bahn.
Da wollten wir eine hoch elliptische Bahn machen und dann quasi am Perizentrum
der hoch elliptischen Bahn, wo er am schnellsten ist, der Satellit,
sollte er dann einen schnellen Vorbeiflug am Apophis haben.
Das war unser erstes Konzept. Und da haben wir eine Bahn genommen,
die gerade noch so an die Erde gebunden ist und hätten dann aber immer noch
eine relativ hohe Relativgeschwindigkeit von über einem Kilometer pro Sekunde,
ich glaube sogar 1,8, wenn ich die Zahlen richtig im Kopf habe.
Das war unsere erste Studie zu dem Thema, aber dann hat ein erfahrener Missionsanalyst,
der Michael Kahn, der vielen auch von seinem Blockenbegriff ist,
Oder auch von Raumzeit natürlich, auf jeden Fall, der darf da nicht fehlen.
Der hat dann aber in der Studie auch gemeint, hey, ab dann,
wenn man quasi noch gerade so gebunden ist, dann heliozentrisch zu launchen,
ist dann auch nicht mehr so ein großer Unterschied in den Kosten und was man an Energie braucht.
Und tatsächlich wurde dann demonstriert, nee, man kann auf eine heliozentrische
Bahn zu sehr, sehr ähnlichen Kosten wie dieser schnelle Vorbeiflug.
Und dann haben wir uns sehr schnell auf Studien eingeschossen,
die eben ein Rendezvous machen und keinen schnellen Vorbeiflug,
weil man da halt richtig viel mehr bekommt.
Das heißt, man schickt Ramses quasi einmal um die Sonne?
Genau.
Nur einmal?
Genau, nur einmal ein Jahr und dann fliegt er da mit.
Und wenn er dann zurückkommt, dann ist das sozusagen genau rein zufällig hinter
diesem, das heißt auch Apophis hat auch so eine Bahn?
Genau, wird genau auf die Bahn von Apophis gemacht. sodass es dann nur noch
ein bisschen bremsen muss beim Ankommen.
Wie ist dann die Relativgeschwindigkeit?
Zwischen Apophis und Ramses? Ja gut, Meter pro Sekunde, der driftet dann da
halt so ein bisschen vorbei, hin und her, also der bleibt da auch wirklich eine ganze Weile.
Okay, also es ist dann wirklich wie bei Rosetta, dass man da also wirklich direkt
dahinter einparkt und jetzt auch in Ruhe sozusagen das beobachten kann.
Und was passiert dann bei der Ankunft?
Also dann trennen sich diese kleinen CubeSats von Ramses ab.
Genau genommen nach einer Erstcharakterisierung, weil diese kleinen CubeSats,
da muss man wissen, was man tut und wo man hin will und einen Plan haben und
da benutzt man natürlich,
dass das große Mutterschiff erstmal in Ruhe alles charakterisiert,
aber die Idee ist schon, dass das deutlich vor dem Erdvorbeiflug ist und dass
am erdnächsten Punkt die beiden dann im Einsatz sein können.
Wie groß war jetzt der Churyumov-Gerasimenko im Vergleich, also der Komet,
den sich Rosetta angeschaut hat?
Faktor 10 war der größer. Okay, das heißt wir haben es jetzt mit einem sehr
kleinen Objekt zu tun, was dann dementsprechend auch kaum Gravitation hat.
Das heißt, Ramses schert jetzt
sozusagen ein, fliegt dann in was für einem Abstand zu dem Asteroiden?
Der Abstand variiert genauso. Was man typischerweise macht bei diesen Rendezvous,
also beim Co-Orbitalfliegen, ist, man versucht natürlich nicht perfekt,
Co-Orbitalfliegen zu fliegen, weil ansonsten würde man irgendwann einfach unweigerlich
aufeinander zudriften.
Man versucht es natürlich immer sicher und redundant zu machen.
Das wurde bei Rosetta so gemacht. Das ist bei Hera im Plan. Das wird bei Ramses
auch sehr ähnlich umgesetzt werden.
Da hat man Erfahrung. Man hat eben langsame Relativgeschwindigkeiten,
wirklich nur Meter pro Sekunde.
Aber Bahnen, die sich dann in diesem Low Gravity, in diesem Niedriggravitationsregime,
die sich dann quasi hyperbolisch verhalten.
Das heißt, man geht zum kleinen Schubs und driftet dann vorbei.
Das kann auch Tage dauern. Dann gibt man noch einen Schubs und driftet in eine andere Richtung.
Und geht dann halt ein Muster, wo man alle Längen gerade sozusagen abgescannt
hat. und durch die Rotation dann die Breitengrade kriegt.
Und bleibt auch länger, dass man eben die Pole auch irgendwann ...
Der Schubs wird durch was ausgelöst? Was sind das für Triebwerke in dem Moment?
Ähm, bei Ramses, da muss ich jetzt gucken.
Ich glaube, das ist ein normaler Position-Thruster. Ich glaube, Coldgas oder sowas.
Ich müsste genau gucken. Ich habe jetzt eine Weile nicht mehr in die Tech-Specs reingeguckt.
Okay, aber irgendwas, was auf jeden Fall zuverlässig ist, keine Ionen-Geschichte
oder sowas, sondern das ist einfach so klassische, kleine Impulse.
Genau.
Eiert das Ding sozusagen um diesen Asteroiden drumherum. In welchem Abstand,
in welchem mittleren Abstand ungefähr?
Das sollten idealerweise nur wenige hundert Meter sein.
Es hängt da ein bisschen davon ab, wie die Staubumgebung ist und alles.
Das wird am Anfang auch weiter sein und man kriegt dann immer näher ran,
wie bei Rosetta eben auch.
Aber das ist ein Asteroid, das ist kein aktiver Körper wie der Churyumov-Gerasimenko.
Da hatten sie immer wieder dazu genötigt, dann wieder Abstand zu nehmen.
Durch die Koma die ganze Zeit?
Ja, also am Anfang, die erste Überraschung bei Rosetta, das ist jetzt ein kleiner
Exkurs halt, Was ein bisschen unterschätzt wurde, wie hell die Partikel sind, die ausgeworfen sind.
Und das hat dann eben, es muss ja teilautonom gehen.
Man kann ja nicht mit einem Joystick die Mission fliegen, wo man mehrere Lichtminuten
Versatz hat, bis es ankommt. Das wäre ein Rezept für Katastrophe.
Das muss teilautonom gehen mit einem Navigationscomputer und der hat dann halt
gesagt, ja was ist denn hier los?
Also ich sehe ständig, ich sehe Sterne im wahrsten Sinne, wo keine sind.
Und da hat er sich natürlich furchtbar aufgeregt und dann wurde hier bei uns
beim Flight Control Team gesagt, nee.
Wir müssen da ein bisschen mehr Abstand haben, dass wir mehr Sternenfeld haben,
dass diese Partikel nicht so direkt alle vorbeifliegen.
Wir brauchen ein bisschen Sicherheitsabstand. Das war toll.
Man muss ja die anderen Sterne noch sehen, um sozusagen die eigene Position
immer wieder festmachen zu können.
Genau. Und damals waren wir, war ich Teil von dem Team, was die Operation teilweise
monatelang im Voraus geplant hat.
Und das ist schön, wenn dann gesagt wird, du müsstest jetzt anders machen,
ihr habt nur noch Wochenzeit.
Großartig. Okay, aber das Problem habt ihr bei Apophis wahrscheinlich nicht, das Ding.
Nee, da gibt es vielleicht ein bisschen Staub, das wäre auch schön interessant,
und Destiny Plus könnte dann am richtigen Moment auch hoffentlich ein bisschen
was davon mitnehmen, da weiß ich, dass Staubdetektoren an Bord sind,
sein werden, zu dem Zeitpunkt dann.
Nee, das ist auf jeden Fall, man kann deutlich näher ran.
Also wenige hundert Meter ist die Zielvorstellung.
Okay.
Und das wird dann sehr, sehr spektakulär. Weil was sich dann ergibt,
ist, glaube ich, ein Bild. Das wird nicht Astronomy Picture of the Day.
Ich glaube, das geht eher Richtung Astronomy Picture of the Century,
wenn man dann einen Asteroiden in all seiner Pracht sieht und der Hintergrund
von dem Bild ist die Erde, nicht der Weltraum.
Das sollte, glaube ich, dann allen klar machen, was da passiert.
Okay, also jetzt, wir sind ja immer noch am Anfang. Also wir haben jetzt einmal
den Weg um die Erde gemacht, dann scheren wir hinter diesem Asteroiden ein,
tasten uns langsam ran, so auf 100 Meter Abstand, sagen wir mal.
Und dann eben durch diese kleinen Boosts hüpft man immer wieder sozusagen auf
eine andere Relativposition, aber behält im Wesentlichen dieselbe Geschwindigkeit bei.
Ja, man driftet immer relativ, dass man nicht gravitationsmäßig gebunden ist.
Also sollte es zu einem Safe Mode kommen, und das ist die Idee dahinter,
hinter diesen Trajektorien, hinter diesen Mustern, die man fliegt,
sollte aus irgendwelchen Gründen eine Abschaltung kommen,
würde man gefahrlos langsam driften, hat Zeit, alles wieder in Ordnung zu kriegen
und kommt wieder zurück.
Genau, man will jetzt noch nicht kollidieren. Genau, man will nicht kollidieren.
Man hat ja die richtige Bahn sozusagen, jetzt nicht auch noch,
den dann nicht noch auf die Erde schubsen. Ähm,
Okay, aber jetzt ist erstmal Abtastung angesagt, das heißt man gewinnt jetzt
erstmal sehr klare Bilder, vielleicht auch was für die Wand.
Sehr hochauflösend nehme ich mal an, also auf 100 Meter Distanz,
also was kriegt man da so für eine Pixelauflösung vermutlich hin?
Ein Dezimeterbereich sein auf jeden Fall.
Ein Pixel, ein Dezimeter, okay, das ist ganz gut eigentlich.
Also genau, so ein Laptop sollte man irgendwie merken, dass da was ist,
wenn da einer liegen würde.
Okay, und ist das eine reine optische Abtastung oder gibt es jetzt auch noch andere Instrumente?
Also mit was schaut man da noch drauf?
Das Hauptinstrument, also was die Hauptarbeit macht, ist eine monochromatische
Kamera, aber natürlich soll da auch ein hyperspektrales Instrument oder ein
multispektrales Instrument sein, das eben in vielen Wellenlängenbereichen abtastet.
Auch ein Infrarot-Instrument ist angeplant.
Und dann eben, last but not least, dass man eben mit einem Radar da leuchtet
und das gestreute Radarsignal auf der anderen Seite empfängt und dann so ein
bisschen einen Einblick bekommt, was da im Inneren los ist.
Okay, aber dann kommen jetzt die CubeSats zum Einsatz. Genau,
das sind dann die CubeSats. Das heißt, wenn man diese erste Abtastung vorgenommen
hat und jetzt hat man schon mal so ein schönes 3D-Modell von dem Teil,
dann würde man sagen, okay, alles klar, jetzt klinken wir hier unsere Freunde mit aus.
Das ist ja dann ein etwas intensiverer Modus.
Und wohin bewegen sich jetzt diese beiden?
Also arbeiten die beiden dann nur miteinander oder sind die beides dann sozusagen
Anstrahlobjekte für das Hauptsystem?
Also hauptsächlich ist erstmal einer die Anstrahlstation und beim anderen ist
noch ein bisschen eben die Instrumentierung ist noch nicht 100% festgelegt.
Da wird zum Beispiel noch diskutiert, ob ein Seismometer an Bord sein sollte.
Also dass er dann wirklich auch da liegt, wenn es spannend wird.
Also dass der CubeSat landet auf dem, also dann doch.
Naja, aber ganz, ganz, ganz zart, ganz hauchzart abgesetzt, weil niemand mag
dem Ding einen Impuls geben.
Okay, aber das, okay, ich meine das ist ja sportlich jetzt, wenn man jetzt sagt,
wir wissen noch nicht so ganz genau, was wir für Instrumente da haben.
Nein, nein, nein, es gibt konkrete Vorschläge, konkrete Konzepte und es müssen
nur noch die Einzelheiten ausgearbeitet werden.
Okay, aber wir befinden uns jetzt immer noch in so einer Phase,
wo das noch nicht hundertprozentig beschlossen ist, sondern man baut das dann zusammen.
Gebaut werden sie noch, genau, ja. Aber das ist ein Cube-Sats,
also das geht dann schnell.
Das ist ja die Idee, deswegen war unser ursprüngliches Konzept komplett CubeSat
basiert. Das wäre dann richtig großer gewesen.
Aber die Idee ist schon, irgendwann mal dahin zu kommen, dass man ein Konzept
hat, einen Bauplan, und die schnell zusammenschraubt auf irgendeinen Microlauncher.
Wenn die Dinger mal irgendwann sinnvoll werden sollen, müssen sie ja mit einer
gewissen Frequenz gebaut werden.
Und das ist die Idee, dann irgendwas zu haben, was kaum Bauzeit hat,
schnell auf was draufgepackt werden kann und losgeschickt werden kann im Bedarfsfall.
Okay, auch wenn jetzt noch nicht alles ganz feststeht, also die Aufgabe der
beiden Kübsatz, also der eine Kübsatz wird vielleicht landen und dann noch vielleicht
ein Seismometer haben, also sozusagen Erdbeben,
messen, also was auch immer man dann Asteroiden beben.
Ja.
Ist das so? Weiß ich nicht, weiß man nicht, also deswegen will man es rauskriegen
sozusagen, hat man noch nicht gemacht, oder?
Genau, genau, das ist Wissenschaftler bin ich an dem Punkt dann voll mitgenommen.
Man weiß es nicht, das ist der beste Grund.
Die beiden CubeSats sind nicht identisch.
Nee, hochgradig nicht.
Jeder hat sozusagen eine bestimmte Aufgabe. Die eine ist vielleicht zu landen
und die andere ist im Wesentlichen als Gegenradar- Objekt zu fungieren.
Und der, der landen soll, wird dann auch, das Konzept wird sehr ähnlich sein wie bei Hera.
Juventus ist da der Radarspezialist und auch mit Gravimetern und sowas.
Das soll halt im Endeffekt die Komposition genau vermessen, also was Struktur angeht.
Und Milani bei Hera ist der eben mit dem Multispektralgerät,
das dann nochmal komplementär und ergänzend zu Hera messen soll.
Und sowas ähnliches wird dann auch bei Ramses sein. Dass eben der,
dass eben erstmal einer so ein bisschen alles anguckt und sich dann zur Ruhe
setzt, während der andere dann die Radarsachen entgegennimmt.
Okay. Und...
Wie lange wird jetzt diese Begleitungsphase dauern?
Also wo wird dann jetzt der Astrid das erste Mal eingeholt?
Und wie viel Zeit vergeht, bis die Ramses-Mission dann beendet ist?
Also wie gesagt, es soll idealerweise zwei Monate vorher ankommen,
um Zeit zu haben zum Untersuchen.
Dann natürlich im entscheidenden Moment hochpräsent sein und eingeschaltet bleiben
und keine Probleme haben.
Das ist immer so der spannende Teil.
Und dann soll sich dann Orisiris Apex dazu gesellen. Destiny Plus soll zwischendrin
mal kurz vorbeirauschen, wenn es klappt.
Und es gibt noch andere Bestrebungen, dahin zu gehen.
Also China plant auch, da kurz vorbeizugucken mit einer schnellen Vorbeiflugmission,
eben um auch da mit zu trainieren an dem Ganzen und mit teilzuhaben.
Und das muss dann koordiniert werden.
Da gibt es dann auch Samepage hat dann auch so eine Art,
Taskforce eingerichtet, so eine Apophis-Arbeitsgruppe, das ist ein temporärer
Teil von Samepage, wo eben jeder, der da hinfliegen will, dazu kommt und sagt,
hier, wir wollen mitmachen, wir haben das und das vor,
dass eben nicht am Schluss wieder dann da irgendwelche Verkehrskollisionen um
den Asteroid Also Samepage nochmal.
Space Mission Planning Advisory Group, also SMPAG oder Samepage ist sozusagen,
wie man es hier so normalerweise ausspricht,
genau, die das dann alles koordiniert also ja richtig was los sozusagen,
also richtig so eine kleine Astro-Party die da stattfindet, nur 30 Kilometer,
entfernt 30.000 30.000 Kilometer entfernt aber das ist ja quasi nichts,
Und Ramses ist dann sozusagen der erste Begleiter, die anderen schauen mal kurz
vorbei, Apex kommt dann später erst dazu,
weil die ein anderes Anflugkonzept haben oder weil das sozusagen Absicht ist,
erst später dazu zu kommen.
Ich meine, Ramses wird ja dann auch weiterhin, also Ramses begleitet ja sozusagen
sowieso den vollständigen Vorbeiflug dann sozusagen mit.
Genau.
Bleibt dann auch dabei oder wie?
Genau, die Idee ist, dass Osiris Apex und Ramses sich quasi dann gegenseitig
mitfotografieren können, sozusagen, dass man dann so ein Handover hat.
Ich meine, das ist zum einen, ist es...
Aber Ramses bleibt doch weiter aktiv.
Genau.
Wie lange noch?
Wie lange darüber raus, das weiß ich jetzt. Da stecke ich nicht in der Detailplanung
drin, muss ich einfach ganz ehrlich sagen.
Aber ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass er jetzt kurz nach der Erde sich abschaltet oder so?
Auf jeden Fall sollen beide Missionen zur gleichen Zeitdaten aufnehmen.
Das ist ganz wichtig, weil dadurch bekommt man einen großen Luxus.
Osiris Apex ist noch mal mächtiger von der Instrumentierung her.
Es hat noch mal größere Instrumente. Das ist die größere Raumsonde,
die hat ja Benno genau vermessen.
Und die Idee ist, dass man dann eben zur gleichen Zeit, im gleichen Zustand,
unter den gleichen Bedingungen Daten aufnimmt und dann kann man die Kreuz kalibrieren,
die Daten der beiden Sonden und dann sind die wirklich einszeits übertragbar.
Und das ermöglicht dann quasi, es erleichtert es dann quasi mit den Osiris-APEX-Daten,
mehr Rückschlüsse auf das Vorher zu ziehen.
Also Ramses macht Osiris-APEX besser, Apex macht Ramses besser und das Ganze
ist dann mehr als die Summe seiner Teile, was den Datenschatz angeht.
Plus diese beiden Konzepte zu haben, ist auch Redundanz, sollte jetzt dann...
Ich hoffe nicht natürlich. Sollte irgendwas schief gehen mit Ramses,
wäre immer noch Osiris Apex auf dem Weg oder sollte Osiris Apex nicht mehr in
Betrieb sein aus irgendwelchen Gründen, gäbe es trotzdem noch Ramses und man
würde es nicht verpassen.
Aber um jetzt auch weiterhin mit Apophis mitzufliegen, bräuchte man im Prinzip
fortlaufend weitere Korrektur der Bahn.
Also dieses Spielchen müsste eigentlich die ganze Zeit so weitergetrieben werden.
Gebe ich jetzt mal davon aus, da ist dann nicht so viel Sprit vorhanden,
dass man das ewig vorantreiben kann oder geht das Ding noch einmal um die Sonne
und bis ins All, bis man ihn nicht mehr hört?
Also das kann man schon eine ganze Weile machen. Also die richtige Energie,
die ist ja schon reingepumpt ins System.
Es ist ja koorbital mit dem Asteroiden.
Das heißt, man hat wirklich nur noch diese kleinen
Meter pro Sekunde Geschwindigkeitsänderung. Da ist dann einiges an.
Und die Kommunikation, also wie weit kann man mit den Antennen,
die da dran sind, arbeiten?
Na, wir müssen Ramses natürlich schon so konstruieren, dass es nicht den Kontakt
mit der Erde verliert. Wir sind ja irgendwann auf der anderen Seite der Sonne in Erdbahnnähe.
In Erster Nährung.
Also etwas unter zwei astronomische Einheiten muss es machen,
aber aufgrund der Bahn geht es ja gar nicht weiter weg.
Deswegen ist es wirklich eine simplifizierte und geschrumpfte Version von Hera
in mehrerlei Hinsicht, weil Hera muss ja weiter raus auch.
Weiter von der Sonne weg, weiter von der Erde weg letzten Endes.
Also Hera ist schon das größere System.
Aber wenn jetzt Ramses mit Apophis mitfliegt und Sprit reicht jetzt aus,
Kommunikation funktioniert, dann fliegen die jetzt beide sozusagen der Sonne entgegen.
Ja, um die Sonne rum. Naja, also erstmal Richtung… Die Sonne ist in einem der
Brennpunkte der Ellipse.
Ja, okay, aber jetzt meiner Wahrnehmung, also nähert sich jetzt erstmal der
Sonne noch eine Weile an, geht
dann um die Sonne rum und das würde Ramses dann auch alles mitfliegen.
Und auch wenn Ramses auf der Rückseite der Sonne ist, wenn wir definitiv keine
Kommunikation mehr in halbwegs erträglicher Zeit schaffen,
wäre es vorstellbar, dass man ihm sozusagen ein Programm mitgibt,
dass er auch diesen Umflug sich immer noch im richtigen Abstand aufhält oder
ist es dann schwierig, da die Balance zu halten?
Die Balance ist viel mehr beim Budget, denn der Betrieb kostet Geld.
Die nominelle Mission endet, wenn die Datenrate dann runtergeht.
Genau wie bei Hera ist auch.
Die nominelle Mission endet dann quasi mit der Sonnenkonjunktion.
Der Plan muss sein, dass dann alles leer gepumpt wird an Daten.
Es gibt natürlich dann nochmal die Möglichkeit, wenn alles noch super funktioniert,
nochmal zu fragen, hey, das und das könnte man noch machen.
Da könnte man vielleicht, ganz zum Schluss muss natürlich dann irgendwann bei
Ramses, weil das so eine erdähnliche Bahn ist.
Es ist immer noch eine Erdbahn kreuzende Bahn, er wird zu einem Apollo,
er wird noch nicht zu einem Amor.
Die Bahn kreuzt noch die Bahn der Erde und dementsprechend müsste Ramses dann
auch irgendwann auf eine sichere Trajektorie gebracht werden,
wo man sicher ist, dass die Sonde nicht in 100 Jahren dann auf uns zukommt.
Weil wenn eine Sonde sich der Erde sehr, sehr nah nähert, das erkennen unsere
automatisierten Systeme.
Da gab es letztes Jahr eine nette Geschichte zu.
Wo was runtergefallen ist, was nicht hätte runterfallen sollen?
Nö,
kann ich ganz kurz erzählen. Also letztes Jahr war der Juice Vorbeiflug.
Aber Juice hat auch große spiegelnde Solarpaneele. Juice ist die Jupiter-Mission.
Genau. Und das hat einen sehr nahen Erdvorbeiflug.
Und wenn jetzt die Sonne auf diese Paneele scheint, kommt dann eine Menge Licht
zurück. Und da man aber nur einen Lichtpunkt sieht ...
Wenn man noch nicht die a priori, die Linkage macht ständig,
wo sind unsere Missionen?
Und dann taucht da plötzlich ein Objekt auf mit einer gewissen Magnitude.
Und das würde sich dann zu einem über 50 Meter großen Asteroiden schätzen lassen.
Und man merkt plötzlich, das kommt uns sehr nah.
Dann geht hier die Feuerwehr los.
Dann klingeln bei uns die Alarmglocken.
Okay.
Wir haben recht schnell gemerkt, so ohne Moment, die Bahn ist verdächtig.
Ist ein alter Bekannter. Mittlerweile machen wir das automatisch, den Abfluss.
Aber okay, das heißt, man müsste eigentlich Ramses schon noch,
bevor es um die Sonne herum geht, aufgeben dann, oder reicht es?
Ja, man müsste irgendeinen Kompromiss finden, wann Wann ist das Operationsbudget aufgebraucht?
Wann kriegen wir da keine Geldmittel für die Mission weiterzumachen?
Es muss an einem Punkt sein, wo noch genug Treibstoffreserven sind.
Und da muss ein Entsorgungskonzept halt einfach.
Oder beziehungsweise Entsorgungskonzept ist eigentlich, was man im erdgebundenen
Bereich macht, eben um die Müllproblematik nicht noch weiter zu verschlimmern in Zukunft.
Aber auch Sonden, die im erdnahen Raum fliegen, die müssen dann auch quasi garantieren,
dass sie nicht direkt auf dem Planeten zu fliegen.
Aber was ich nicht verstehe, ist, wenn Ramses sozusagen jetzt mit Apophis fliegt,
dann haben die ja eigentlich dieselbe Bahn.
Genau.
Aber Apophis kehrt doch jetzt auch nicht wieder zur Erde zurück.
Doch, doch. Apophis ist auf seiner Bahn um die Sonne, die Erde ist auf ihrer Bahn um die Sonne.
Und das nächste Mal ist es wieder 30.000 Kilometer entfernt?
Nein, nein, nein. Das ist dann wesentlich viel, viel, viel weiter für die nächsten 100 Jahre.
Nur die Bahn von Apophis bleibt eine sogenannte Erdbahn-kreuzende Bahn.
Also das heißt, der Orbit vom Apophis, der ist zum Großteil dann außerhalb,
momentan ist das eher innerhalb und das wird dann andersrum.
Aber der Großteil ist zwar außerhalb, aber ein Bereich ist auch innerhalb der
Erdbahn und das heißt rein durch…,
Bei Entwicklung der Bahn und pure Statistik kann es irgendwann mal sein,
dass die Bahn von Apophis, die
Bahn von der Erde kreuzt, wo beide zufälligerweise gerade an dem Ort sind.
Das meinte ich damit, auf die nächsten 100 Jahre wird das nicht passieren.
Die Abstände sind dann sehr, sehr groß.
Aber auf 10.000 Jahre, wer weiß, ob sich dann wieder eine Kollisionswahrscheinlichkeit ergibt.
Ich denke mir halt nur, wenn Ramses sowieso mit Apophis fliegt,
dann kann es ja auch erst wirklich ein Problem werden, wenn auch Apophis ein Problem ist.
Okay, da müssen wir sich um beide kümmern. Das wäre vielleicht auch nicht so toll.
Ja gut, Ramses wäre kein Problem. Wie jeder andere Satellit in der Erdatmosphäre verglühen.
Das ist nicht so fett.
Wir müssen dann tatsächlich aus Planetary Defense Gründen genau wissen, wo ist diese Mission.
Nicht, dass die uns irgendwann erschreckt. Wenn es wo ganz anders ist,
als wir so vermuten würden.
Ja, super. Ich fühle mich sicher. dem Planeten kann nichts passieren, dir passt gut drauf auf.
Die nächsten 100 Jahre sehen wir kein Dino-Piller.
Reicht mir erstmal. Super, ja, dann hoffe ich, dass es weiter interessant bleibt.
Vielen Dank für das Gespräch, für die Ausführungen hier zur,
Planetenverteidigung und den weiteren potenziellen wissenschaftlichen Einblicken
in Asteroiden, weil da kann ja auch rein wissenschaftlich eine ganze Menge bei rauskommen,
weil jenseits von dem Verteidigungsszenario spannend, was die Steinbrocken da
draußen noch für Geheimnisse.
Preishalten. Alright. Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören. Das war's bei Raumzeit. Bald geht's wieder weiter.
Ich sage tschüss. Bis bald.